[Music]
uh
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
now
[Music]
i know it's wrong
but i don't care
[Music]
the fire is
[Music]
is
[Music]
eyes for your eyes
[Music]
think about it
[Music]
later about it
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
think about it later
[Music]
is
[Music]
as the world ended an unprecedented
crisis magnus carlsen and chess 24 acted
quickly to create the first online chess
tour of his kind working 24 7 we brought
together the best players in the world
for the largest online prize fund ever
broadcast live in 10 languages the tour
innovated and filled the void created by
the lack of in-person play reaching more
people than any online chess event ever
there was fun and laughter
okay it's time for russian hackers to
attack
internet
[Music]
last hope
there was tension and controversy
yeah
and then give up the phone
this is hopeless unish is fast these
days
okay so
we will have a fantastic match tomorrow
i'm sure
jan is angry as hell now
but i knew she also got his little so
let's see
there were instructive learning moments
we have discovered
uh e6 was a very strong move for nepali
as she opens up the diagonal of the
queen and at the same time shuts out the
d5 bishop from the defense black has to
play rookie seven to protect the popcorn
and the seventh rank but now the queen
comes from the f5 queen f2 threatening
rook of seven and its curtains so the
position is collapsing right now here
black has to resign and there was lots
of great chairs
wow it's really
an incredible game like showing how a
completely lost position
can gradually turn into a winning
position if you just trade all the right
pieces it's really this game is really a
must pass on on the trades what you
should be trading and what not and when
i said that
trading the queens and the bishops uh is
good for black i never imagined it would
ever happen because it's just it was so
far away from that
wow and it's a special resignation from
dingley right four unique online events
and a grand final made up the magnus
carlson chess tour and the world took
notice
[Music]
the magnus carlsen chess tour has been
the most watched online chess event in
history already it has become the
world's most prestigious series of
online tournaments as the first season
approaches its conclusion we want your
help to do something even bigger our
partner for the tour final is kiva the
non-profit with a mission to expand
financial access to help underserved
communities kiva does incredible work
providing micro loans to help people
around the world create opportunity for
themselves and their communities when
the pandemic started kiva set up a
global covet 19 response fund to help
small businesses get back on their feet
their target to raise 50 million dollars
to support thousands of people around
the world chess24 wants to help make
that happen during the tours final we
will be donating 50 of all proceeds from
new premium memberships to kiva go
premium and you will not just be
supporting us and getting the best chess
entertainment out there you will be
supporting people in times of need
through kiva and if you are premium
already you can buy sponsored premium
memberships for schools in cities and
countries of your choice in our shop
let's show how chess can play its part
together
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you find the good move uh find a better
one
but the thing is that i think that you
find a good move like
what's the point of finding a better one
if you don't find a better one and just
wasted like 30 minutes on the clock
then you're probably gonna lose the game
[Music]
[Music]
what a game holy
whoa and magnus gave up his bishop with
the move rook a
a peter
yeah this is
this is a already something i mean an
indication that something went wrong
yeah for magnus he he miscalculated he
missed maybe maybe not miscalculated he
just blundered his bishop takes the a5
idea you know you you put the bishop on
a square
uh oh but hang on night for queen eight
whoa queen a8 that's a turnaround move
oh my goodness queen a8 rook a1 queen h1
nate peter
ding blundered terribly
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello and a big welcome to all of you
joining us for the magnus carlson chess
store benefiting kiva final i am
delighted to be here and today i am i'm
super excited because
the final that's coming up is guaranteed
to blow our minds i mean this is stars
aligning to give us two of the best
players who have shown absolute class
throughout the entire tour to come
together to fight it out to decide who
is the best one of the best ones the
format remains the same but this time it
gets harder because it's not a best of
five it's a best of seven which means
the first player to win four sets
is the winner of the magnus carlson
chess store 2020. let's take a look at
the format let's have that up on the
screen we're going to be having four
rapid games every day to make up the set
uh in case there's a tie we've got two
blitz games which is five minutes with a
three second increment if that's still a
tie we go on to the armageddon the
players are in the armageddon the what
in in the armageddon white starts with
an extra minute that's time odds but
black gets result odds which means in
case of a draw black wins the set it's
all about winning the first four sets to
win the entire final uh i don't know
about you guys but the stamina and the
mental fatigue has to be setting in for
the players yesterday magnus carlsen got
a much deserved and a much desired break
but is he
fresh enough to take on a hikaru
nakamura who's had a bit of a break
who's had time to get ready for this
while magnus after the legends of chess
went on to do more act he played the
symbol with all of us and after that
he's right here in the finals after a
very very
epic semi-final battle against ding
lirin where magnus lost the first set
but bounced back straight with three set
victories what are these two fighting
for
for in my mind it's
the big thing the big prize is the pride
this is the world champion up against
five times u.s champion up against the
world number one blitz player we've seen
magnus carlsen dominate all feed a
ratings he's been the world champion in
rapid blitz and the classical format but
hikaru nakamura still remains
the world number one blitz player on the
rating and he's also somebody who is
widely accepted as being the best in the
world when it comes to shorter time
formats this is an epic rivalry this is
this is the rivalry of 2020 and of
course besides pride and besides ego and
besides showing who's the best in the
world they are fighting for some big
bucks as well because take a look the
runner-up goes back with 80 000
and a very cool 60k jump if you win you
go back with a hundred and
forty thousand dollars now anything can
happen in this match i still think that
magnus carlsen is a favorite but there
is just
so much that we've seen these two play
against each other and trade blow after
blow
we're gonna be talking about that but a
quick reminder if you think you can
predict results and what's going to
happen it's a great time to go and enter
the fantasy chess because the fantasy
chess for the finals is on and you've
got about 15 minutes before the start of
the round to enter this some very cool
prizes for our premium members some very
cool questions like will we see the
scandinavian all the burning stuff right
there for you to answer so if you know
if you know these guys well if you know
what's going to happen go and enter the
fantasy chess
contest let's take a look at how these
two got here their journey in the magnus
carlson chess store
magnus has won three out of the four
events that he's played so split so far
he won the magnus carlson invitational
the adjustable masters
the uh
the legends of chess and now he beat
dinglaren to get to the finals the other
player who completely bedazzled us with
his play was hikaru nakamura he's the
guy who reached three finals in the
entire tour and
here he is
with beating daniel dubois in three
straight sets the most consistent player
who i feel has even at times when magnus
has felt shaky let's not forget the
qualifying stage of the previous events
magnus has sometimes had a bit of a
struggle as well to qualify while hikaru
nakamura has not only made it to the
finals of several events but also
finished at the top of the rankings
in the qualifying stage i think the one
quality that we've seen in hikaru's play
so far has been his tremendous
consistency
and let's also talk about what happened
when these two have been meeting each
other face off during the magnus carlsen
chester the first not even talking about
what happened during the qualifiers
because they were trading blows
throughout the event but also the first
big one the magnus carlson invitational
final where magnus came on top after an
extremely
exciting final
and eventually took the championship of
the invitational and booked his part
into what what is happening today the
magnus carlsen chester final
the second time that they met in the big
match up was at the linderis abbey rapid
challenge and that was all hikaru
nakamura he came back being a set down
as you can see on the screens he was a
set down and then two straight victories
in a best of three match and hikaru
sensationally
knocked out magnus carlsen from this
tournament went on to play dubov in the
final two ball won that final but hikaru
did get his revenge finally in this very
event take a look at what happened the
day hika nakamura beat magnus carlsen in
the linder asabi rapid challenge
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and that was the big armageddon game
that booked a hikaru spot in the finals
in that tournament and knocking out the
world champion
of course they also met in the
chesapeake chesapa masters but that was
in the qualifying stage i think the
magnus carlson invitational final
and
the linda sabi rapid semi-final has been
the tone of when these two have met and
which means we are going to be having a
cracking final this time we spoke to
both players about what they expect out
of it and i think uh magnus knows that
he's up against the one player who's
truly proven that he belongs right here
in the final with his play his energetic
non-compromising striking when it
matters the most and taking his chances
playing solid making very very few
mistakes as hikaru himself said he's
been playing he's been strategically
playing his opponents their style i
think he's just combined this
this entire universal aspect of chess
prep and and shown his a game in this
entire tour and then we asked hikaru
about what it's going to be like facing
magnus and no one can put it to no one
can put it better i think for hikaru
some of the things that are working
great for him has of course been his
consistency the fact that he's a lot he
has a he perhaps has a lot more energy
because he's had a little bit of rest a
lot more than what magnus has stamina
mental fatigue is going to be a big
question
on top of that we've seen hikaru play a
dominating semi-final in this entire
tour on the other hand magnus has had a
demanding tour he's played event after
event he's qualified to the finals in
all of them yesterday it was i think it
was very clear to all of us just how
shaken up and exhausted magnus carlsen
was
is a car going to be able to use all of
that to his advantage in this final and
what is it that works for magnus i think
what works for magnus in this final is
that that he's just bloody too damn good
at chess he's just magnus carlsen and
we've seen him
come out in the hardest of situations in
the most difficult situation to prove
that he's truly the best and i think
hikaru said it just better than anyone
else could have when he said that
everything that hikaru has been doing in
this event there's one guy who's been
doing it slightly better than him and
that's magnus carlsen
and talking about doing things better
than anybody i think the one
overpowering aspect of
magnus's play that we have seen in this
entire tour has of course been different
aspects of the game but the one standout
moment which i think a lot of other
players perhaps have struggled in has
been his end game play i think every
time magnus carlsen has gotten these
opportunities uh you know the the the
clock is shot but it might even look
like an even position or a slight
advantage to magnus he's gone on to
prove those critical points and make the
most of them and we
are in luck because
chesapeal has launched the magnus
carlson course on end games and if that
if that
free lesson was anything to go by this
is going to be absolutely epic we are
going to be learning from the world
champion just how how to get good at
endings how to play like him check out
this trailer
[Music]
there's also a launch offer of a 40
off on the entire course so definitely
have a look at that we perhaps will
never be the world champion but we can
play a little bit like the world
champion at a point when it matters the
most the endings so check out that
course and uh talking about all the
action the besides these besides these
two who we cannot ever stop
talking about of course it's our
audience who has been a big part of this
show sharing your impact chest stories
and just being a part of uh part of all
the excitement that's been happening a
big big shout out to all of you for
following it for engaging with us on
twitter and let's take a look at what
what's your take on the upcoming finals
we had we had farsi max writing in best
of luck to hikaru on the final end game
of magnus carlsen chester even if it
seems like there are very many
possibility possible outcomes there is
always
the one future to win just keep calm and
carry on streaming chess i think the
streaming chess will have to wait as
today hikaru nakamura faces he's one of
the one of his biggest challenges and i
think magnus faces his biggest rival in
a format where both are absolutely on
their a-game i don't think anyone's any
one of them has gotten lucky i think
they both have shown that they are truly
the best in this entire tour with this
demanding format they belong here
definitely the end game
and and some avenger vibes we see magnus
as thanos and
hikaru nakamura is captain america i
love it so let's move on to the next one
we also had chess master more avengers
can't wait to see magnus carlsen doing
his thing
yes magnus is quite the thor with his
hammer on the board every time he sits
down to play i think what's been amazing
has also been his ability to come back
from difficult moments and regardless of
just how exhausted he is regardless of
just how difficult the format's been and
how much chess he's been playing with
the very best in the world in a format
that is so difficult he has truly been
unstoppable so far but this is going to
be a test by fire for the world champion
let's move on to the next one
c day the grand final of magnus carlsen
chester is set to start tomorrow it is
magnus vs zakar who will you root for
tell us what who is your favorite who do
you think will win this match and i know
the answer might feel like magnus is
still a big favorite but i have to say i
think
when we see how the tour has gone and
hikaru's consistency in the qualifying
stages in the semi-finals in finals the
fight he's given knocking out magnus in
one of the tournaments
it's really anybody's final
and tell us who do you think is going to
take it away in a best of seven set i
personally think that
that a big question is going to come on
has magnus recovered he had one day off
is he is he ready to go at it again
because like i said the format only got
more tough let's move on to the next one
we also had edward writing in with the
world champion magnus and hicario being
arguably the best players in the world
at faster time controls right now will
the impact chess finals all come down to
psychology it is going to be epic
it is going to be a cracking epic final
i think we all can agree on this that
these two are truly the best players in
the world when it comes to
shorter time controls and especially you
move that shorter time control to an
online format
i feel that there's a big difference
between magnus and hikaru and the rest
of the bests
on this let's i also see we've got yas
and peter joining us and i think this is
a really interesting
uh interesting point about the
psychology of the event uh let's get
their thoughts let me just first get
this one up magnus carlsen showing the
world why he is head and shoulders above
the crowd well fought dingler and thank
you chess twenty i i completely agree i
think it takes both players to create an
epic match and that's what dingler did
with his fighting spirit he he drew
first blood in his match against magnus
carlsen and yesterday a day before
yesterday the chess that we saw from him
i mean he was better in in all rapid
games but just failed to convert it at
those critical moments and eventually
magnus had his chance and the thing with
magnus is when he has his chance he very
seldom fails to convert them but
congratulations to dingler and for an
epic run throughout the tour
and he's also been extremely generous
and kind by contributing five percent of
his winnings to our kiva support kiba
campaign take a look at the message that
ding had for all of us
chess has helped me a lot
it's my job career
and it also makes me who i am now
in this difficult period
the magnus carl sanchez tour has
provided me
with opportunities to
play and compete and it also brings
company and joy to the chess fans
in addition i joined the
kiva campaign
in order to helping help to help
companies
affected by the epidemic
if that semi-final was anything to go by
the final is going to be just another
level and talking about that to take us
through the action is going to be grand
master yasa sarawan along with grand
master peter lecko the star commentators
of the broadcast welcome uh yes welcome
peter
thank you tanya a pleasure to be with
you as always and great to call the
action the play by play the move by
moves with peter lyko hello everyone and
welcome to the finals peter
yeah thank you yasir hello tanya it's
very nice to be here for the finals it
will be a thrilling final as you already
described i mean so many things had
happened we haven't seen magnus carson
so exhausted as we have seen him uh just
on the last day of his match against
dingley ran that was also the reason why
i refrained from asking him any the
chess questions we very much wanted to
hear what he was thinking about all
those intense fights but i felt it was
the right moment to to give magnus time
to recover for this final and we need
his best here and i'm pretty sure that
magnus is up to the task
absolutely peter and i think this rest
that he got has been extremely crucial
for him
now we're entering this best of seven
contest and yes what do you think do you
think we are going to we are going to
see firecrackers from the very start
from the first set or
do you feel that the play might be
slower today just building up because
they need to ease into the format and
into the finals
uh thank you tony there's no question to
my mind that
that there's going to be ups and downs
the match itself is going to experience
uh
cycles if you will in the chess there'll
be a lot of tactical
slugfests but also a lot of strategic
slow middle game play i think the
players are going to test themselves in
all areas and for me as
we all made our predictions and i
predicted this finals i predicted hikaru
to win
these finals i'm going to stay with my
prediction i'll tell you why
i think the most confident player in the
world where blitz chess is concerned is
icaru
ikaru just really sees himself as the
supremo of blitz chat that doesn't mean
that magnus isn't really really good he
is
but what i think the strategy for hikaru
is going to be
is to try to split the rack rapid games
2-2 and to force overtime blitz games
because that in my opinion is where he
caro feels that he has
an edge whether that's true or not we're
going to find out peter your take
yeah that's uh that's of course kind of
a strategy but
also very interesting for me how the
players will approach the whole match
because
the already the semi-final was something
special with
the best of five and now we are having a
best of seven
and the game just has started and magnus
carson goes for the sicilian e4 c5
knight fc and d6 so magnus is ready to
play the night off against hicary i
believe
all right but tanya you're you didn't
give us your final
viewpoint what are you expecting for
today's
finals the first set
yes i think this format just welcomes
firecrackers i think this format is just
absolutely there is no there is no uh
margin for for being slow here because a
winner is decided at the end of the play
i completely agree with you he asked
that perhaps going into blitz in a
shorter time format might be something
that works for hikaru and it's something
that he's thought about we're gonna see
the action we do have a night off on the
board so definitely no slow play for
these guys a reminder to our audience
stay with us and join us in this epic
final by using the hashtag impactchest
yes peter take us through the action
thank you and uh thank you tanya and
hikaru has played uh the f3
uh line that uh well magnus was playing
again i think you asked peter magnus did
he like it when
his opponent was playing his favorite
opening or defense against him he said
no
and what do you think about ikaru's
choice from a psychological perspective
as well as a choice overall
yeah very very interesting already also
the choice for magnus that he was ready
to play the night off because one thing
you know i want to to mention is that i
felt like we already discussed a lot
that magnus is kind of quite exhausted
and he has had very tough schedule and
he just finished the legends tournament
and now he's playing another final
and that i felt like you know playing
type of positions where he feels
at ease the most would be the logical
strategy and in this regard i was very
much expecting e4 to be answered by e5
by magnus uh however he goes for the
sicily and nylorf i believe there might
have been also the reason that he was
expecting hikaru to play hikaru to play
a certain line which he used to play i
believe hika was the type of player who
used a lot of six move bishop g5s and
maybe magnus fed like he's ready for it
i'm not sure that he he anticipated this
f3 at all on the other hand now also
hikaru is in a territory where he
doesn't really have much experience
exactly we just saw this moves bishop e7
and queen d2 and h5 i
i mean i think for a lot of people in
our audience they get mystified when is
g2 g4 threat couldn't white have started
with g4 shouldn't black in turn have
started with h5
but
uh for whatever
you know theoretical nuances there are
um
[Music]
they have achieved this position and
what can you tell us about this position
peter after the move queen d2 is white
going to castle long or is he going to
go bishop e2 and castle short
well to be honest we had exactly this
position between magnus carson and
england and i think i was mentioning
that i felt like dingley then mixed up
the plans
in that game but here we got a little
bit different move order because in that
game
i think you know it was very interesting
because that game featured bishop e3 e5
knight b3 bishop e6 and magnus played
the move order with queen d2 he did not
play fc yet immediately he used the fact
that he started with bishop e3 he went
queen d2 and after bishop e7 he played
the move fc which was answered by dingle
and with h5 and magnus hesitated like
for one and a half two minutes and he
chose this slightly mysterious little
move bishop e2 indicating that he might
gonna castle short on the other hand
then after dingling played knight bd7
magnus changed his direction and went
for 95 followed by long castles so a lot
of lot of finesses here and now we see
something similar
that hikaru
opted for knight d5 immediately and i
told you i think already during the
broadcast that uh
knight d5 can be answered by knight d5
ed5 bishop f5 and in case if white goes
bishop d3 then after the exchange of the
lights creditship white loses an extra
tempo with queen d2 and queen takes this
d so that's the reason why black feels
like once you place your queen on d2
then this knight x on d5 e takes d5
bishop f5 is very much a legitimate
choice
and now don't be fooled because then is
the real development in the game bishop
f5 happened bishop e2 and bishop h for
check if you just look at this position
the first time you might be completely
shocked that what on earth is this
bishop h4 check after though after g3
magnus had to defeat back to e7 and the
point is that yeah this is slightly
mysterious but i think hikaru himself
played this bishop h4 check bishop e7
back in 2003 with the black pieces so
hikaru knows what what this is all about
so the players are
are opting to use
the favorite weapons of their opponents
against them um now having said
that this is a theoretically recommended
peter this whole bishop h4 check
g2 g3 bishop e7 again i think a lot of
players in the audience and i'm gonna
put my hand up in the air too are
mystified
that provoking the move g2 g3 is worth
two
tempes in the opening can it really be
that the move g2 g3 is so bad for white
and why is that
no it's not clear at all if that is bad
i mean
it's it's more about the psychology of
the position that if you look at this
position after
black captured with the knight and kept
the bishops
one very naturally a plan for white is
simply to castle short let's just
imagine black plays something like
knight d7 then first of all you might go
knight a5
and hinting at the pawn on b7 if black
reacts with queen c7 then you play c4
and the black castle short white
also castle short and somehow white has
a very easy comfortable play with b2b
for coming
followed by some look c1 preparing the
typical brakes through with c4 c5 black
can never play b6 because then the
knight jumps to c6 and this lovely
knight on a5 is very nice deposition
and after
black gives this bishop h4 check and
includes g3 bishop e7 it basically says
that yes i lost two tempi however now
white will not really feel comfortable
castling short because he has weakened
his structure with g3 in this regard
basically it almost like an invitation
for white to castle long but if you cast
so long then one has the argument that
okay if your plan is to expand on the
queen side with c4 as happened in the
game and for example later with knight
a5b4 then with the king on c1 you are
not feeling that happy about this
remarkable uh that uh i i like the logic
and the way you explained
why uh the move g2 g3 and it's just kind
of this moment
where both sides are keeping their
options open i must still say peter as a
classical player myself i i i'm very
skeptical about the loss of the two
tempe we will see
white has played the move c2 c4 hoping
for that knight d7 95
kind of queen side bind
that you mentioned and
magnus was quick to flick out this nice
little move i like it a lot
a6 a5 just to stop white from getting
that buying peter
yeah absolutely i mean this is uh this
is an obligatory move i mean black has
to stop this knight a5 because the
knight on e5 is really so irritating and
we have seen that dingley than in little
bit similar position of course without
it the black black exchanged the bishop
for for that night but he tried to to
slow it down with b6 but later he anyway
was running out of counter play and he
opted for b6 b5 and then knight a5 came
anyway so a5 is a much more natural way
of dealing with this problem and also in
some type of positions the move a5 a4
hitting the knight obesity might be
annoying for white so also white has to
make up his mind what is his plan will
he really castle long and then after a4
let's say go back with the knight to a1
which is not the end of the world
because the knight actually via c2 a3
can head to the lovely square b5 but
still it's something you you have to
think about or you just gonna play a
move like rook c1 which already would
indicate that you are ready to to castle
short and i absolutely understand hikaru
that he's taking his time because this
is not an easy decision
absolutely not an easy decision at all
and i i seem to remember as you were
talking about the a4 and the knight
being driven to a1 where it comes back
to c2 there was a game i believe it was
between alexander krishog and magnus
carlson we saw
a very thematic line of play just like
that and
like you say the the players are making
some very
difficult long-term
strategic decisions
and taking a little bit of time i still
find it remarkable
that
the
that they play these strategic decisions
these very very very crucial ones uh
with just within 30 60 seconds they make
that i must say that for me peter i like
this move bishop d3 a lot the reason why
i like it is because i'm thinking the
trade of bishops and the knight could
come back to d2 maybe pop up
one day on a beautiful square e4
yes exactly i mean if black takes on d3
which is absolutely possible however i
do recall that one of the other ideas of
this bishop h4 check bishop e7 was to
have the option of playing the very
strange looking move bishop hd and i do
believe that there was a time when
hoodini was playing like this and was
really irritating me during the analyzes
that he was insisting that keeping this
bishop is like zero zero if you exchange
it then white has an edge and i simply
did not know how long i have to analyze
this position because
the more i look the more zero zero so
and it was driving me crazy uh and
bishop ac on the board
[Laughter]
well you called it nice call there peter
uh
why
why was zero zero on the board
yeah i mean those are these typical
positions that if you don't know that
engine says it's zero zero you will say
that no way this position ever can be
zero zero because this is such a double
double-edged complex position
but the engines has to evaluate it in
some way and by
saying that it's zero zero it means that
yeah it's double edged for him
wow
okay uh
what can i say uh i thought that the
trade of light squared by ships by the
way would favor white i just didn't know
how much but you know again this next
loss of tempo this bishop to h3 you know
again that's really confusing to me that
what that black and movie continually
move his bishops around and not get
punished i mean i guess it's just also
the don't forget that in close positions
oftentimes you can
uh spend tampi maneuvering and this is a
semi-closed position uh only one pair of
fonts has been traded but again having
said all of that
yeah i mean white is
gaining more and more
time for his development i see that he
has a problem with his knight on
b3 you'd love it to be on say c3 then
you could uh
get it to a nice circuit
uh but it's just like a problem that
he's going to solve one day in the
meantime what do you think uh
magnus's plan is going to be
yeah this is the the big question i mean
hikaru went for long castle basically
after bishop hd he also doesn't really
have any other choice
and
okay somewhere black should try to
develop i mean get the knight to d7 the
big question is in these positions when
to include this move a5 a4 because on
one side you really want to
push this pawn on the other hand the
knight obesity doesn't have a future and
when you push a4 to prematurely too
quickly then actually you might play
into your opponent's hand by
letting him start this regrouping of his
knight as he also mentioned yeah this
this knight is white's uh problem
uh so magnus kept the tension with
knight b7 and hikaru played the move
which he was very happy i think about
because king b1 you can play a tempo and
you are winning back some time and also
hinting at that you know now black has
to record with two options after a5 a4
white still has the same plan or he
might change the route and if he feels
like the knight on e2 can also go to cc
eventually if he plans some king side
action somewhere sometime register g4
then the knight on e2 can be also a
handy in going towards the gc square
trying to attack black king if black
dares to castle short after all sooner
or later black will also have to make up
his mind that to put this colleague on
e8
exactly well you you just kind of uh
set the table really well i mean uh
black's king needs a home
uh the center is okay for now but it's
not always going to be okay one day he's
going to have to castle
short
and
when that day comes isn't g3 g4
going to promise white
uh a really nice attack peter so we do
have a4 knight c1 on the board the
knight is seeking to go as you said e2
to c3 so just imagine castles
uh for black
uh
i mean not that you have to play g4
right away but imagine g4 right away
oh if you like it yeah
yeah the reason i ask is if you take
twice on g4
and then let's say rook
d1 to f1
uh
then i see an open g file
yeah i just didn't want to allow bishop
f3 maybe i can allow bishop f3 but uh
uh yeah i see you know
whites
bishops are looking really good
um
i i i mean
i
i would be shocked if this wasn't like
checkmate game over kind of
thing
yeah absolutely i mean this already
illustrates the dangers and uh also one
of the reasons why black will definitely
not even think about castling right now
uh it's it's more like a long-term
problem and uh also i i very much like
that hikaru immediately used also
blitzed out knight c1 signaling his
opponent that you know you miss your
chance of
pushing my knight all the way to a1 and
to c2 and in fact i'm a very aggressive
player so i want to go after your king
but magnus makes a very nice move and
the typical reaction in these positions
when you are pushing a5 a4 that you go
queen a5 challenging the queen
from d2 i mean you basically
invite white to go something like queen
f2 and then you might have the idea of
playing something like bishop d8
followed by bishop b6 exchanging the
dark spot bishops because that would be
a nice strategical uh
achievement for black
exactly and i i like the smoke queen a5
a lot because the alternative of
castling short was like walking into
a kind of a
uppercut
white is ready to play the g4 move make
the pawn sacrifice
and the bishop on h3 might be really
for lorne uh kind of trap now after
queen eight five
uh
you know i i'm feeling like i should
just
just be better uh
but
while i like to keep queens
um
i'm not sure i want to spend the tempo
to do so peter like
should i be playing i don't know queenie
two and just
asking black what he wants to achieve or
should
uh white play
well in fact
icaru made the decision for us by the
way they're playing very quickly he
traded queens uh peter
yeah he traded queens which is also a
very typical idea in this positions
however
i'm little bit surprised but it has a
very concrete idea i mean hikaru
followed it up with luke g1 basically
hinting that yes we changed the queens
however gc g4 is still a big issue
because the bishop on hc might get kind
of trapped after g4 and
the big question is that
can black
allow himself to play something like f5
stopping the threat of gcg4 in in that
way but that also makes a very very
strange feeling towards the bishop on hd
nevertheless black has the idea then
also maybe to go g5 and then later to
push f5 f4 if necessary if he feels that
the bishop is in danger in any case we
are in for a very very interesting
dynamic end game
absolutely wow and f5 on the board
you're right
uh
normally speaking we don't get a chance
to see black using his maturity quite so
concretely
also i have to question somehow for me
the rook on a5
feels
better place than on a8 as it does
support the move knight c5 should black
need it but let's take a look at finally
we can calculate maybe something very
consequent
92 peter
and if you play knight the pardon me 92
and if you play g5 my intention was to
play knight c3 and just ignore what was
going on on the
king side
yeah that's uh very very logical
i mean usually this is a big
big strategical fight don't be fooled
that it's an end game because it's still
very very messy and very complex
the fact is that
black still has this strategical idea to
to somehow change the dark square
bishops with bishop d8 bishop b6 on the
other hand when the white knight gets to
b5 pushing the d6 pawn then it might not
be so easy and also when you push for
example g5 then you have this problem of
uh that the bishop has to defend both
pawns g5 and the d6 pawn so you might
not not be able to carry out this
strategical idea with bishop d8 bishop
b6 that's exactly the reason why g7 g5
you might not really want to do
but uh
[Music]
but the reason why i mentioned this g5
was that isn't white threatening to just
move the loop for example to e1 and try
to play
knight g1 harassing the bishop on h3 but
there is this argument that whenever you
move your rook to e1 then black might be
able to plea move like bishop g2 but
still you can answer it with knight g1
so all kinds of finesses here here lot
to calculate
absolutely that's funny i like what
you're saying rook e1 and knight g1 and
bishop g2 and it's sort of like be
careful of the tiger you're inviting to
dinner i mean you might be the dinner uh
if you trap the bishop you're a genius
peter but sometimes that bishop
you know
ends up uh
being more irritating
not not quite the target you would hope
92 on the board uh peter so from your
point of view
the moves that
black should consider or maybe bishop d8
g5
um
do you think about castling short and
finally saying okay my king is going
kingside or do you prefer to keep it in
the center
keeping your options open
yeah very very tough call i mean there
are so many nuances to to take care of
and i absolutely understand why magnus
is spending his time taking his time
usually from my
experience i have to say that whenever i
analyzed these end games i had the
feeling that whenever you made a move
you had the impression that the side who
made the move is right
and
and now that white played the move 92 it
looks like wow we are discussing all
white's plans and it looks so beautiful
but believe me if suddenly black finds a
good answer we might have exactly the
same arguments to to explain why black
is doing great and in this regard i'm
not very curious to see how magnus will
deal with his neck very next move
exactly
um
again all of the moves that you've
considered g5
bishop d8 castles
maybe a small argument for king f7 as
well i just like
you know
the rook on h8 isn't that purposeful
one of the things that we've kind of
mentioned is that the bishop on h3
could very easily suffer
that's why the idea of g5 f4
was kind of your
first instinct and when you go g5 and f4
that was why also having your king on f7
might be useful because the g file
could easily become opened um
getting it right getting the the the
moves and the proper sequence
uh so so very important but i must say
uh magnus is burning a lot of his clock
to
find the
correct sequence peter
yeah absolutely
i mean even somewhere i do recall some
game by uh caruana and dominguez it was
a little bit different but they played a
very high level
uh
game in in this structure and in this
very special specific line and magnus
chose the move short castle so he feels
like yeah the dynamic aspect of the
position is very very important he wants
to be able to to use this uh
f4 or e4
idea somewhere because now his look on
f8 is very active so he can make good
use of it in case he feels uh necessary
to take direct
action
and yeah that game i mentioned was in
thessaloniki in 2013 the feeder grant
privilege dominguez not only won that
game but he also won that
that tournament he was in really really
good form
okay so castles i i understand what
you're saying it introduces the dynamic
that the rook on f8 is potentially
x-rating x-raying
the f3 pawn so that the move f5 f4
could create a tactical skirmish uh
one of the things maybe that
hikaru was that attracted he karu
to trading queens on the a5 square was
that maybe he could pick up a tempo
against the rook and neatly sidestep
the move f5 f4 something to be said for
bishop d2 followed by knight c3 peter
to be honest i would be quiet relief
from the black side if somebody kicks my
look away
a5 with a move like bishop d2 because i
do believe that this bishop on east is
such a wonderful piece and okay yes it's
true you are kicking my rook back but
okay please do so
i feel like now something like knight c5
and also the idea of bishop d8 bishop b6
activating this bishop might gain in
strength once you you remove this bishop
from e3
okay just continue the line for us
please knight c3 uh obviously i'm
i'm anticipating what exactly what
you're saying that it should your bishop
go back to d8 knight b5 harassing the d6
bond was kind of
what i was hoping i'd be uh achieving
yeah and afterwards do you know what
comes to mind
yes exactly
uh we we're too much uh
are we children of tigran petrosia and i
don't know i think that he certainly
showed us that we can sacrifice
exchanges peter yeah definitely and to
be honest i would never even uh think
about lying something like this yeah i'm
a prophylactic student yeah
so if i understand my opponent is
signaling this uh
threat even like two three moves ago i
will just make sure that no no no no
okay i understand you want this you're
right you're gonna get it but we have
some real dramatic
hikaru chose the more natural knight cc
and magnus is trying to use this dynamic
with this phone sacrifice e5 e4
[Music]
uh
call me skeptical
it's very very hard for me to believe
that e5 e4
is uh good uh
explain to us why it is good peter i'm
gonna start with the obvious capture
yes i think that if you capture
definitely the idea is knight e5 and now
after i played the move e5 e4 the light
squad bishop suddenly starts to be very
very important even and i'm hitting your
bishop claiming that if i get this and
we open up the position then my bishop
on hc will be wonderful returning to f5
or to the light squares and you will
have some problem also the pawn on c4
might be lose and if after knight e5
you're gonna play bishop e2 i might have
the move f takes e4 and if you take
knight e4 i suddenly have this bishop f5
that's what i meant by short castle
giving all these dynamic possibilities
and this is what we are seeing now
wow well now that you put it like that i
may have to dial back my uh distaste for
the move e4
because as you say that's just it seems
to be that like this
still a little discomfort in white's
position that the light square bishop on
e2
isn't as powerful when the when black
gets his bishop to f5 he seems to be a
happy camper
yeah and now we also see how clever and
super smart computer already in 2013
yeah by saying that you know this bishop
h4 check bishop e7 and putting the
bishop on hc has a real strategic
purpose in long term so kudos to the old
engines as well
yeah the pawn on g3 boy if there was
ever a desire to
bring upon backwards g3 g2 so the f3
square
is also a very nice weakness so captures
knight e5 on the board
and yeah somehow the spawn on c4 is a
little bit uh
irritating uh
uh
i don't know uh
suddenly things are getting
i mean i i feel like i might be losing
control but maybe not peter if i play
bishop e2
and i'm assuming you were going to
capture on e4
and this play will justify black's
decision to play the move e5 e4 but c4c5
uh a counter thrust peter
wow
wow that's uh
that's actually very much in the spirit
because when you feel like your opponent
has done e5 e4 you think like i want to
give this back to you yeah i mean
exactly
let me toss you with some c4 c5 and
let's check how you're gonna feel about
it right the the question is simply that
i might ignore it and i might just
continue with my plan of uh trying to
get the light squared with knight f3
yeah
you know it it's funny how you you can
have a blind spot for a moment there
earlier you pointed out that knight
takes e4 is going to run into bishop f5
i thought somehow by by by playing c5
i made the thread intake you got
recapturing on e4 that much stronger
okay but so having uh put it like that
i've got a
[Music]
oh i don't know if this worked i sorry
if you take the move c5 back for a
second i think i'm going to do it in the
wrong way but if i go rook yes take on
e4
rook david iv
the the move i was thinking that was you
would play knight f3 and i wanted to
play rook e4
knight g1 rook e7 and i was trying to
calculate
or triton to judge
whether this was a justified
play by
white
hmm i don't know
yeah i mean
the idea was beautiful but the outcome
i'm not sure about yeah exactly exactly
alexander allen kind in this two-volume
series my best games said that in one
position peter it's a classic quote by
alec
um
falling into
my opponent's trap
was the quickest way of winning the game
nice
okay we do have a
as usual a different approach
by hikaru he's played bishop b6 peter
yeah he has played the move bishop b6
and now okay six is coming and you know
i'm wondering that you remember in the
semi-finals we managed to
to to find the moves and we were
offering the same moves it seems like
the players stepped up yeah i mean they
are in the finals and we are not able to
to reach out to their moves exactly they
they definitely seem to have uh
different approaches different ideas
magnus's
castles in particular
followed immediately by e5 e4 that was
not the direction
i was thinking of at all i was thinking
like you in the direction of g5 and so
forth
and then
uh
hitting the rook
with bishop b6 no i was thinking that if
we were going to hit the rook we were
going to do it with bishop d2 because
sometimes the bishop goes from d2 to b4
you know when the knight is on b5 and so
on in any case he has played
uh unexpectedly with bishop b6 rook a6
bishop d4 and what is
his idea because
black can now capture the two bishops uh
peter
yeah i mean there are all kinds of
questions there is also the move knight
f3
also forking basically i mean it seems
like white
wants to give up or has to give up some
material it's another question that may
be actually giving up the
exchange with the phone and keeping the
light square bishop is not even such a
bad exchange for white because he keeps
nice center grip but still it's uh
somewhat intriguing what we are seeing
here and knight fc on the board and he
called c4c5 what on earth is happening
here
[Music]
wow
a very very sharp tactical
skirmish i thought we were going to we
were settling in for a semi-closed
position peter
we could demonstrate to the audience our
wonderful positional strategic
understanding and
the board just blowed up
yeah okay i kind of uh
mentioned that don't be fooled by this
seemingly queenless position because
it's it's just a very complex media game
position and all these
end games with their dynamics uh
is the way to to treat this position but
i mean this bishop b6 bishop d4 followed
by c4 c5 despises things even more up
but you know i just feeling wise can't
believe that it should work out for
whites i mean it feels like black
species are so active and
more naturally placed that somehow some
exchange sacrifice or whatever should
work out more in black's favor that's my
feeling okay
feelings aside we do have d6 take c5 on
the board regaining
the pawn sacrifice by e5 e4
and what do you reckon will be the most
uh
likely scenario here the bishop on d4
hit being hit
is it going to retreat it's very easy
because hikaru has played the move
bishop e3 and once you see the move
being played it looks perfect sense okay
i would have gone with bishop e3 as well
yeah let's meet you
me too uh
one of the benefits i want to say of
white sacrifice pawn sacrifice c4c5 is
he has opened up
for a route for his passer on d5 if
white very very much wants to play
bishop takes a6 and d6
which by the way just explains why black
didn't take on g1 i think
magnus judge that after takes takes uh
take the bishop take on g1 with the
bishop
i think uh i think magnus judged this
and said he didn't want to face
that move
d5 d6 so he he kept the rooks on the
board uh peter
yeah
i think it's uh very natural and the
rookie f6 and also luke h1 played
i have to say that it feels to me like a
very very intense and very high quality
game
i can very well imagine that in a
classical game players would be taking
like half an hour time
for for their next moves here they have
to rely on their intuition
very very tough call and look at this
what is happening bishop g2 had been
almost blitzed out also let's not forget
about the time situation
one minute 40 versus hikaru little bit
over three minutes
uh very very sharp battle i mean battle
of titans i would say
wow talk about a chaos on the board
uh rook h1 says to uh black if you want
to take my exchange you gotta hunt it
down with your light square bishop
you take the rook on h1 but you're gonna
lose the pawn on h5
so as compensation for an exchange i'll
have a pawn a good light squared bishop
and the pawn on a4 would be hanging at
the end and magnus has played a3
and you know we we talked about the
potential weaknesses of this
amazing world champion magnus carlson we
said
if there's anything you can do you got
to get a chaotic position well
i mean guess what
he carl did achieve that part
is it good for him or not that's the
question peter
yeah very very difficult to say i mean
this move ac
was a very well timed
and very annoying move to face from the
right side because
if you ignore the move like it happened
in the game then
believe believe me you are quite
irritated by this pawn on ac but the
reason is why hikaru did not take on ac
that taking on ac also weakens his king
and all of a sudden also black's bishop
dark squad bishop will be very very
powerful blight black might be able to
switch to luke b6 check
not clear where this white king should
go because king a1 would be met by
bishop f6 hitting the diagonal otherwise
some retreat after king c2 with knight
before check would have been very
unpleasant so
pc is the practical move i mean you feel
like you have to keep the shelter for
for your king but magnus continues with
knight d4
yeah this is the this is also the real
problem is that
um
you know the spawn on a4 was weakness
uh suddenly it got to be more than
irritating we could see almost in this
case if uh that there's a back rank made
possibility this pawn on a3
is a suddenly very very disturbing i
wasn't 100 sure
that any move on the queen side was
required peter i might have even gone
for h2h3
if you take on b2 uh not forced of
course but just in case oftentimes i'm
kind of happy that pawns on b2 and i
might have just gone g4
and said okay uh
now i'm going to keep my f pawn maybe on
a good day i've got knight e4 and this
pawn on b2 isn't
going to
uh
survive in the long term that was not
what ikaru did he did play the move b3
and as you were about to point out
knight d4 does hit the f5 pawn peter
yeah it hits and we see also the big
difference compared to your line hc g4
because yeah and after knight d4 we are
missing the move gc g4
but to be honest the move h2 hd is
probably much more easy to to suggest in
analysis than to play it over the board
with little time because right if after
hd something goes wrong you will be
blamed that how could you play so slowly
if if of course it turns out to be the
the very powerful move then people say
that of course you should have played hd
it was obvious so
it's very tough for the players to to
make all these judgment with very few
seconds on the clock by the way now both
players under one minute in this very
short conversation
okay uh i see knight takes f5 i don't
like knight takes f5
i was about to say can i deal with it
technically by rook f1 knight f5 bishop
g5 peter
yeah that's uh one of the questions i'm
also calculating
heavily okay one thing black can also
always just sacrifice back the exchange
and say that okay i have a perfectly
fine solid stable position exactly what
i need for time trouble on the other
hand
maybe black feels like that he is better
and he wants already more than that but
down to 10 seconds so you really have to
oh
knight f5 very very very dramatic uh
game here as bishop f bishop g5
uh knight five on the board bishop g5
like you said i can just
return the exchange
and then for the dark square for the
price
of the dark squared bishop black gets
some really nice
play
uh at the end uh
peter because after all that pawn on a3
is still very irritating and we did see
a trait of brooks oaks it looks like
after the move knight e4
hikaru is essentially making an offer of
a draw
basically that that was the point that
uh after duke and i'm pretty sure magnus
fed like there should be some option to
continue but done to 10 seconds he fed
like okay no no i mean
this is the first game of the match
right the finals i have to settle in i
shouldn't be risking here because
it's very easy with few seconds of the
clock to to blunder something and in
this respect knight xf5 bishop g5 knight
v6 was a very sensible professional idea
black would actually be even better if
not for the fact that white can
immediately exchange all the pieces
which hikaru made good use of it and
after the exchange of the bishops i mean
the knights it was clear that it's just
question of time when the game ends in a
draw and the green game had ended in a
draw already
wow uh
i must say i i have this uh feeling that
this was an excellent game for a rapid
game if you had shown me this game and
said that it took place in a classical
uh tournament game i would have said
yeah that was a well played game
both
players seem to show
what their relative trumps out of the
opening might be and i just have to tip
my hat uh tanya that
that felt like
a damn good game
absolutely yes a damn good game it left
me breathless i mean a drop but in this
manner just leaves no doubt in our minds
just what an epic struggle this is going
to be for both players i do think a draw
in the first game with the black pieces
we sort of seen this narrative before in
the tour i think it kind of
works out a little better for the player
playing black because now he's got time
to come back with white but recaro's
made his intentions extremely clear he's
not afraid of magnus he is going for the
most dynamic lines and the most
combative play on the board and i just
want to quickly show you guys a very
cute idea that i i was looking at with
the computer while the game was on and
if we can just
go back to the moment when hikaru played
rook h1
after knight f3 bishop b6 rook a6
and i think this entire concept by
hikaru of playing bishop b6 which in the
beginning looks like wait did he just
miss rook a6 bishop d4 knight f3 in this
position but this entire construction
that he had just shows that his
creativity is on point today and here uh
let's just go on a little bit
c5 takes and rook h1 after bishop g2
there's a very interesting suggestion by
the computer which is simply to come
back rook g1 now
and the point is that
here the best move for black is actually
to go back bishop h3 and repeat because
check this out if you grab the rook on
g1 right now white's got this really
pretty into meso with e5 on the board
and then picking up this knight on g1
after this and these two stunning pawns
on the board it would have actually been
a big big advantage for white i love
this idea and um i'm not sure if if you
guys discuss this briefly on the
broadcast probably not because also
making this move like rook h1 and coming
back group g1 is just
i think it's really cute um um a missed
moment i wonder if magnus would have
gone bishop h3 would would it have been
a repetition much early on but i'm glad
that it wasn't because what a firework
of a game that was absolutely a cracking
start
to
day one of the finals and as we can see
the other cracking news is right below
me i am so proud of the chess community
and all the donations that are coming in
for this brilliant course that chess 24
is so proud of supporting
kiva a not-for-profit organization which
has pledged to raise 50 million dollars
to help businesses to help entrepreneurs
to help startups in underserved in
isolated communities survive an
extremely difficult year a very
difficult time by raising money from
them and for them and chess 24 will be
donating 50 contributing 50 of all
premium memberships during the magnus
carlson chester final benefiting kiva to
this cause and i think it's it's just
been
so impactful to have the game of chess
in our lives that it just makes perfect
sense to
give back to the community yet again
by through chess and i think this is the
reason yes peter that we've got we've
got guests like tani coming into our
show and talking to us because these are
the stories that truly highlight how
chess has has made a difference and been
this
positive catalyst in in a family's life
that had to flee nigeria and settle down
in the united states as refugee and then
then chess comes in and
dreams can become a reality and now we
just go a full circle
by contributing and helping
people in very difficult situations and
businesses which have been affected
by through the game that has given us so
much in such a difficult time let's also
take a look at yes have people have been
enjoying our audience our beloved
audience because for whom really this
entire broadcast and everything that we
do we're doing what are their thoughts
on the action that happened in round one
let's get up the conversations from
twitter
how to improve a friday afternoon watch
the final of the magnus carlsen trust up
between hikaru and
magnus
indeed absolutely i think it's not just
today it's the next seven days we've got
it's a best of seven which means the
player to win the first four sets will
qualify not qualify because this is the
end of the road will be the winner of
the magnus carlson chess tour 2020 lots
of action coming up and like we've seen
what just happened in game one if that's
the tone that we're gonna get for the
rest of the day you're going to need a
lot of coffee for this
let's move on to the next one
and this is a photograph thank you so
much rishi for sending this in this is
actually a photograph from the grand
chester uh in uh november in calcutta in
india that happened in 2019
and uh
if this was magnus carlson in between
rounds it was a rapid format
just give me a second
it was a rapid format and we saw magnus
between games what does the world
champion do nothing just kick some ball
around dribble some
dribble and shoot it around and then get
ready for the next game and of course he
went on to win the event and this was at
the terrace of the of the tournament
hall where all the action was happening
a very memorable event and yes you've
also been such an integral part of the
grand chess store
i think we can't wait for all that chess
action to return but for this year for
2020
this store is where it's at this final
is where it's at because
this is the very best in the world the
two absolutely fantastic fast format
players battling it out for the highest
the biggest price fund in an online
event the most elite the strongest
players playing against each other
just what a final we've set up and uh
check out this
check out this video coming up for more
information on everything that's been
going around the magnus carlsen chester
our partner for the tour final is kiva
the non-profit with a mission to expand
financial access to help underserved
communities kiva does incredible work
providing micro loans to help people
around the world create opportunity for
themselves and their communities when
the pandemic started kiva set up a
global covit 19 response fund to help
small businesses get back on their feet
their target to raise 50 million dollars
to support thousands of people around
the world chess24 wants to help make
that happen during the tours final we
will be donating 50 of all proceeds from
new premium memberships to kiva go
premium and you will not just be
supporting us and getting the best chess
entertainment out there you will be
supporting people in times of need
through kiva and if you are premium
already you can buy sponsored premium
memberships for schools in cities and
countries of your choice in our shop
let's show how chess can play its part
together
[Music]
so consider going premium and investing
in your own chess education and
improving your own game with the help of
the very best that are there out there
who have done some brilliant brilliant
video series on chess 24 but you can
also you can also donate membership you
can buy premium for your friends for
your family for anybody who's fallen in
love with chess in this extremely
difficult time and by doing that support
the community as well fifty percent of
all premium sales will be used will go
towards kivas campaign in helping the
community in helping businesses survive
the
pandemic let's take a look at all the
other action that we've been having on
twitter because you guys have been
loving the fact that
that just
the final that we have set up how do
arbiters prevent cheating in chess 24
magnus carlsen chester how are
accusations of cheating or engines use
handled loving the tour fantastic
production thank you so much osmosis
garfield and i think this is a really
great question to ask because a lot of
you have been i think this is something
that comes into everybody's mind the
moment you take chess
from over the board to online i think
the perils of online chess and how is it
that we are able to deal with this um is
something that of course all organizers
have looked into and chess 24 has taken
extremely extremely strict measures
against this for this store in my mind
the first thing that comes to this is of
course the fact that these guys i mean
for me i would not even think that they
would ever ever go down that road but
that's not how chess works because
you've got to have the measures in place
there's so much at stake big bucks at
stake and just to make everything more
authentic these these strong measures
need to be in place and for this event
there are a minimum of two but sometimes
even three cameras around the players so
you the arbiters at all times can see
the screen the computer screen but can
also see the entire room where the
players are sitting the arbiters can
also see the players at all times uh
there's absolutely
no chance and
no margin for any foul play at all
because the players are being looked at
their room their cameras everything is
in place the arbiters are keeping a
constant eye on it and we often see the
players
looking at their left or towards their
right and we wonder what is it that
they're seeing and of course you know
besides thinking about we've seen these
guys do that during the game not looking
at the board but besides that a lot of
these players actually have
two dual monitors so they've got another
monitor set up next to them where they
can see their opponent on the zoom call
to actually get a look at their body
language and even this monitor can be
viewed by the arbiters so
absolutely nothing to worry about that
about about any of this uh chess 24 has
ensured that there is absolutely no
scope for any foul play
the only heartbreaking thing for me
honestly with this whole internet online
setup has been dealing with
with just the
unpredictability of online connectivity
which we've seen tingling really suffer
with but i hope in the future we can
work out something around that as well
let's move on to the next one
and
we had
jonathan tistel writing in the sharpness
levels of opening in the carlson ding
match have been
off the scale maybe rapid chess is the
future and then malcolm replied uh i'm
trying to work
but i can't take my eyes off this two
cracking games already
you guys are absolutely right and i
think this is the point that we were
trying to discuss that we were
discussing during the pre-show today
that just that how this format and
online chess just welcomes
welcomes insanity and madness on the
board but insanity of an extremely uh
high level it's not like you're just
dropping pieces and blundering uh we see
players go for the most combative
difficult complex positions because
there is i i think with online rapid
chess there is a little bit more margin
for taking risks and because you know
the clock situation the player does your
opponent does not have that much time to
really make use of
you know perhaps a novelty which you
might not use in over-the-board
classical time format because your
opponent has enough time to counter it
but here with the clock ticking you can
take your chances you can perhaps come
in even slightly dubious positions as
long as it's posing the maximum
questions to your opponent because it's
just not about your skill of how well
you calculate but also how fast you
calculate is rapid chance the future i
personally miss classical over-the-board
chess and i think it's a great question
jonathan because at the end of it this
online boom that we've seen off of rapid
and blitz
in um in the online format i think this
will definitely have reflect when we do
return to over the board chess how it
does it is to be seen and i'm gonna get
yas and peter in because we are about to
lift off soon yes how do you feel about
this um do you think that perhaps the
format playing for rapid games the short
time control is
one of the reasons why we are seeing
such aggressive play from the players
not just these two but throughout the
tour
oh thank you tanya indeed i like the
twitter and uh shout out to
uh jonathan tisdale we played together
in my first u.s junior championship but
there's no question that the format
itself these sets of games if you will
really does
um encourage
uh sharp combative games
and this idea of seizing the initiative
peter early with uh your opening prep is
so
important uh in these games where you
have little time what what what really
struck me about game one peter i want
you to jump in on this was that despite
the fact that both players were really
short of time in a very chaotic position
it seemed to me that they were both very
calm and they made the right
decisions
yeah absolutely i mean uh yasir you are
perfectly right i'm completely
shocked also that with such a low time
they were playing
extremely well and
making very
interesting decisions because all these
things you know with
playing rook h1 i mean it's clear that
white is going to sacrifice the
not only sacrifice but he will lose the
rook but
how to give it and then just within few
seconds the players come up with some
very interesting deep ideas it was truly
impressive but we also have now ready
the liftoff to the second game
which started with d4
[Music]
ah magnus so we're going to see the
classical
e4 openings by ikaro and d4 openings by
uh magnus well hikaru who is we've
mentioned before has experimented with
the king's indian quite successfully
he's also experimented with a leningrad
dutch
uh but
recently i want to say in the last few
years he's really gone for the classical
queens gambit declined approach
as
uh peter with bishop e7 i think magnus
was prepared with the bishop f4 line and
now instead
we've got
this mess on the board i think it was
shaq mamidarov who was kind of
showing how it it's to be played but
peter please take us through it because
uh this is really sharp stuff and it's
cutting edge
yeah i mean i remember i immediately
understood what you meant because i was
following this broadcast and when in
saint louis i think like two years ago
there was a game between
mamedyadov and fabian okaduana but it
was exactly kaduna who played this line
with black against chakriar right after
the game uh shakri i was telling in the
interview with maurice or with you i
already don't remember but something
like this that i knew that this line
exists and this line is quite good but i
simply don't know how to to play against
it you know
right i i felt like it was a very nice
moment because a lot of honesty there
from from shakriar ever since this line
had been taken very seriously because
black started to play it many many times
even on the highest level and now by now
white has come up with ideas however
hikaru
in my mind never had played this line
and i'm also not remembering magnus ever
facing it so this must be some kind of a
surprise for magnus
exactly now when hikaru sat down today
if we could start from the opening
sequence
uh after four moves nobody's surprised
like knight c3 now hikaru has been
playing bishop e7 and bishop f4 has been
really been getting a great workout is
what i want to say
and
it seems to me like a ton of games has
been played from this exact position and
hikaru has been on
on the black side in a lot
a lot of games uh but hikaru captured on
c4
and that was kind of an invitation to
let's say the vienna after e4 bishop b4
but now
and everybody used to play bishop before
and there was and there's been tons and
tons of games but the move b5
uh
was
i mean i think it existed many years ago
but everybody kind of rejected it
because after e5
knight d5 knight takes b5 they just
looked at black's position and said it's
bad
this is bad and then along came chess
engines and chess engines said well wait
a minute after the move knight v6
it's really not as bad as it looks
and you think to yourself well it
couldn't be as bad as it looks because
it looks like black has just ruined this
structure but as you're pointing out
it's very easy to see where black's
pieces
uh
belong and peter the structure is bad
but the dynamics are good
yeah i mean the whole point is uh that
it's it's much sander than it looks and
really it's not obvious that who should
do what now in this this position
because if er as this game shakira of
kaluana game pointed very nicely out
that if white just plays without any
specific idea then in long terms
actually black has a very nice easy
play
so in this regard white has to be really
energetic here and i think if i'm not
wrong the move played by magnus ac is
maybe even a novelty at least i don't
recall it and magnus goes ac bishop ec
also very specific idea because it would
have been much more natural that white
plays bishop e2 for example black plays
bishop b7 invite castles black i don't
know plays bishop e7 or knight c6 and
this used to be the debate and there was
this moment he also mentioned in
previous broadcast this famous game in
2018 in baton rouge olympiad between
dinglin and duda where white came up
with this queen did it was i think not
the first game where this queen d2 queen
f4
queen g4 plan was played but it became
one of the main topical ideas and white
was putting a lot of pressure on black
but most probably by now black players
had understood how to wield how to deal
with that
and it was time and who else if not
magnus cars and the world champion with
his fantastic team uh will show the
world how may be to find the new concept
and the ac bishop pc on the board
a3
uh
stopping ideas of both bishop b4 check
maybe knight c6 to b4 to d5 but a2 a3 is
a tempo knight c6 and black says wait a
minute hey
didn't you just give me a juicy square
the b3 square maybe i can put my my
knight there and be disturbing bishop e3
on the board um okay peter
uh
give us your assessment your judgment
uh white for choice and if so why
you know my first thing that comes to my
mind is uh the fact we are talking about
this manager of kaduna but if it's
really in 2018 as i remember it it means
that it was just couple of months prior
to the world championship match between
magnus carson and fabiano caruana and in
this respect i very much believe that
magnus and his team must have studied
this
system very seriously and i wonder
whether this is the bishop e3 something
which magnus and his team has prepared
for the match or is that something that
magnus
picked it up later but there is already
some kind of speculation in my mind
about this it's so i'm so happy you
brought up that point peter because i
thought this was very very special so of
course we all remember in 2018
famously in the london world
championship match 12 classical games 12
draws
magnus retains his title in the tie
breaks congratulations to him
but you know 12 consecutive draws and
then magnus went on a tear
he just had a tremendous
tremendous
2019 uh
player of the year player of the decade
it was amazing and asked about why his
2019 had been so successful magnus said
well
frankly i got to play a lot of the
novelties that i didn't get to play in
the london match and i suspect you're
absolutely right
that the move a3 and bishop e3
was a preparation that magnus had made
for uh his world championship challenger
fabiano and is it something that hikaru
um
is playing a little bit with fire uh but
for the moment uh it still seems like
[Music]
a pretty
even position let's say
i don't know start developing the pieces
bishop e7 peter
yeah
we have been talking about this bc
square that with the move aceley yes why
did stop any kind of knight before ideas
which we also see now after vice played
quincy too that it's very sensible
and another very important moment that
the question was how to deal with this
knight bc move which disturbs mites look
and this very little move queen c2 makes
sure that the look is perfectly
comfortable whenever black jumps knight
bc it turns out that it's going to be
premature since white will just move the
look to d1 the look is perfectly placed
on the d file stopping any kind of c7 c5
breaks in the future because the look is
is perfect there and also protecting the
d4 pawn and finally black will
sooner or later answer what you're gonna
do with the c4 pawn how you're gonna
take care of it so
hikaru doesn't play knight b3 of course
he goes a6 kicks the knight back and
after knight cc plays the developing
move bishop e7 one thing i want to
mention about this position this yeah it
looks like very strategical everything
uh but also
full of
attacking ideas for example especially
after seeing the white queen on c2 some
moves like you know h4 followed by ideas
with knight g5 just making sure that
black will not feel comfortable castling
short because then knight g5 will hit h7
and you have suddenly serious problem to
face
this ac bishop pc queen c2 feels to me
very flexible and i'm and i'm loving it
wow um yeah i i'm sorry i'm hating asics
i mean it's just
that that move just leaves a very very
sour uh taste in my mouth it felt like
the knight on b5 first of all could get
kicked by
bishop a6 even queen d7
uh
has an attraction you know you just boot
the knight away
and then for example after knight c3 you
might play bishop b7 um whereas somehow
i think the pawn is actually better on
a7 than it is on a6 so i'm not really a
big fan of this move a6 i maybe i'm
being over critical
but
i i even a move like rook b8 by the way
i i could imagine that rook b8 instead
of a6 so that you could you know
use the half open b file
uh
that feels a lot more
attractive and if you go knight takes a7
you might get
your hand caught in the cookie jar after
say bishop d7 the knight on a7 maybe
he's gone a little bit too far but
am i being overly critical peter about
the move a6
to be honest i
i get i really get your point because
the knight on cc is so lovely and and
the move a6 doesn't feel like it it does
so much and i very much liked also your
idea with queen d7 tempo i mean give me
this tempo the queen on d7 is uh
so much more useful than than this pawn
move a6
one thing is
also we should mention that yeah hikaru
jumped to this line
to surprise magnus but on the other hand
i mean he had to learn some
really specific variations in order to
play this line
but after facing this ac bishop is the
moves
it's not easy to be
over the board facing magnus carson with
the black pieces especially if you don't
have enough experience in this type of
positions and i can't call hikaru
playing this type of structures yes he
does play
queen's gambit accepted where you might
be able to get little bit of something
similar but still this one has a very
special spice in it
i'm not sure that he feels so
comfortable over the board
well uh in any case he has played after
a6
knight c3 bishop b7
um
i hikaru's certainly not committed
himself to castling short uh
maybe because of what you suggested
peter the h2h4 knight g5 you're taking a
a page out of
frank marshall's playbook frank marshall
was a famous u.s champion
uh who's
what we would call a head hunter he was
always looking to attack his opponent's
king
and a move like h4 and marshall was very
famous for sacrificing on h7 and
following up with knight g5 um
the move bishop b7 suggests to me that
icaru
may still
go queenside or leave this king in the
center peter
yeah i think it's uh very important for
black to keep the king as long as
possible in the center not to not to
make it easy for white to make up his
mind because now so we see magnus slow
down why did he slow down i'm pretty
sure that he he could be blitzing out
bishop e2 or he could be blitzing out h4
i mean both moves are very
sensible
but he can only make one of them and he
has to make up his mind and finally
just at this very moment he has played
the move bishop e2 it's the more solid
move
certainly it protects the knight on f3
uh prepares h4
it reminds me quite forcefully about the
uh magnus carlsen dingler in game magnus
carlson sacrificed
quite two pawns in fact and he brought
his knight to c5
and got great compensation i can imagine
in the very near future
that's precisely what white wants to do
he wants to go knight e4 to c5 peter
and
you know we talked about the weak square
b3 a moment ago when uh the rook was on
a1 and knight b3 could be very
disturbing
now it doesn't look like knight b3 is
going to disturb anybody
absolutely i mean the rook on d1 is
perfectly
e4
pleased
c5 is an idea which is always hanging in
the air uh basically what i would like
to add that once
white will play the move short castle
then it will be a clear signal for black
that he can go short of himself and now
by taking his time he carries exactly
considering the the pros and cons and
he's still faced with this uh really
unpleasant uh question that if i
prematurely castle too early then maybe
white will play h4 and how i gonna deal
with this knight g5 step you just don't
wanna
don't wanna put yourself in in such a
in such shoes besides it might be
objectively very very dangerous and bad
so i'm waiting some prophylactic move
the big question is which is this
prophylactic move because if you play
queen d7 which you already indicated
when it would have hit uh hit the knight
on b5 and it would have been a tempo
after wasting the move a6
and then playing queen d7 it might run
into the idea you mentioned with knight
e4 knight c5 it's also not something
black really wants
and then what exactly is a move like h7
h6 an option just to wait but do you
really want to put this pawn on h6 so a
lot of lot of things to consider
exactly and the uh
times of the players have been
they they they've been pretty much
playing move on move uh no
big differences in the clock
um
[Music]
here's a question a rather uh direct
question that i might ask
is i'm thinking long term
that this pawn on c4 is going to be a
problem peter and i'm thinking long term
i might have to play rook c8
and c5
and take on d4 to ensure that the pawn
on c4 survives i can imagine that white
might want to play 94 and maybe even 92
and somehow i've i've got issues with
this pawn
so
should i play
bishop
d5 and just invite
knight takes d5 e6 takes d5
well i i don't think that this rook c8
c5 plan is is justified i fully
understand what you mean that yeah this
opponent c4 will need extra guard
somewhere but on the other hand if black
would be able to to sacrifice this pawn
for the
for getting the light squared bishop for
it and just exchange one pair of knights
i think black black would immediately
sign this scenario because then the
light squared bishop would give perfect
uh compensation and also let's not
forget this juicy d5 square and i
believe that this d5 square is juicy as
long as you don't occupy it because
whenever you put a piece there bishop or
knight or whatever you feel like you
missed out of the opportunity of placing
the other piece
on that on that very square and in this
regard i really believe that the move
hikaru played is the most natural one
uh queen d7 the move also that you very
much wanted to wanted to play because
the queen was doing nothing on d8 queen
d7 is kind of flexible you might be
hinting at ideas like luke d8 also if
the white knight moves to e4 there are
ideas like queen a4 suddenly hitting
widescreen on c2 this is i think one of
the extra arguments why queen d7 is so
natural
okay so queen d7 it is now having said
this one of the things
um i'm sure anna rudolph in her course
of uh
you know attacking course uh one of the
things i've always liked
about a pawn on e5
is that you can leverage it
towards a king side attack what i mean
by that is that the pawn on e5 just
simply denies
the defense of knight the square f6 and
it means that there are you know good
attacking chances thanks to the fact
that this defensive knight has been
pushed aside so
i mean
after white castles i'm thinking to
myself well where's my play going to be
maybe i'm much happier playing h4
h5 king f1
and a rook lift on the king side and say
i'll castle by hand
but i'll use my rook
up the h file what do you think about
them apples peter
yeah very interesting suggestion very
much in the spirit and i think one of
the headaches magnus is having now
because
if he would be able to play the move
short castle he would have played a
tempo and
gain like at least two three minutes
compared to his
clock situation right now but on the
other hand this h4 rook hd idea is so
tempting on the other hand maybe he is
also thinking about i'm facing hikaru
what type of game i want to play and now
finally magnus mid up his mind and he
goes with the plan h4 i'm i'm loving it
that we are seeing such play
exactly well it it also you know do you
sometimes play the board peter or do you
play your opponent what i mean
like
hikaru said it very well and it really
reminded me of my own mindset when i
played michael tall uh he he hikaru said
about donald
i want to play board chats i just wanted
to you know reduce the chaos and not
uh
you know inflict any self-injury and so
he wanted to play a game where you know
tactics were at a minimum and when i
played against michael tall i did
precisely the same thing i wanted to
bore him to death uh
but
in this case the move h2h4
is playing both the board and the
opponent i just think it's the best move
but i also think it's a move that really
um
puts the pressure
on hikaru like now he's got to
um
find the best move in return and he has
played to move bishop c6 a move you
mentioned that queen a4
might might have been awkward to me is
bishop's e6
intending
bishop a4 that's
that's quite something uh
um peter
yeah that's one real big question does
black really want to play bishop a4 or
he just wants to make sure that the
knight will have to stay on cc because
whenever this knight moves then bishop
a4 will be a big issue
to be honest when uh
hikaru played the move bishop c6 and
played it almost a tempo i have the
feeling like hikaru understands that
he's not so happy about the possession
and
he wants to play a little bit against
magnus's clock because magnus has spent
burned more time than than maybe he
should have he's one to five minutes in
a very complex position i believe
objectively it looks really promising
for white but you need to be very
precise the fight is still ahead and in
this regard uh having three four uh
extra minutes on the clock can be
exactly that little bonus extra that
hikaru needs to
later when things get really messy might
help him practically
exactly and by the way we did see the
follow-up
with the rook lift rook h3
oftentimes you want to play the move h5
as a prelude to this move because if h5
provokes
the move h6
then rook h3 rook to g3
uh is nice because then g7 g6 is simply
unplayable the magnus felt
that
um
the tempo was important and he just
played rook h3 right away peter
yeah he played luke hc
probably we have to little bit at least
anticipate what's hap what happens after
a move like bishop a4 or maybe perhaps
even rook b at first because it would
also make sense try to
put the pressure on the b2 pawn and then
after bishop a4 knight takes a four
something like queen takes a four or
knight a for hitting the b2 pawn is uh
even more more annoying
and uh i think this explains my magnus
fed like maybe hurrying activating the
look might be more important than the
thematic h5 as you as you just very
nicely explained because you would love
to get that and if you are assured you
feel assured that you're gonna get that
then you're gonna play h5 first
but uh by playing luke hc i believe that
magnus signals us that no no i don't
have time for it because black has some
the counter play going and ruby on the
board yeah so hikaru does not want to
sit still but wants to generate his con
his own counter play with bishop a4 or
knight a4 wow okay so i see the move
rook b8 and i go okay
uh
that
you know that gives me a lot of
information i thought for a moment there
that black was simply going to castle
queen side
and when i see the move rook b-8 i go
okay now i don't have to worry about
queen side castling now i have to worry
about knight a4
and bishop a4
and that's i i feel like you know i just
learned a great deal so when i see that
move i think to myself okay play rook g3
you're not going to castle like that's
just walking into all that suicide
so i'm thinking
you're almost obliged to play king f8
because g6 just looks
awful uh as a french defense player and
and and and and making so many dark
square weaknesses on the king side i'd
be so
reluctant uh peter this just feels
like
the opening gone wrong i i like magnus's
position i don't like his clock
yeah perfectly agreed i mean uh the the
point is the way you described king of
it you know when you mentioned king
isaiah oh dear oh my god but the
alternative g6 has the same feeling
right
i mean and if you have to choose between
move like king fe g6 one certainly has
the feeling that something went wrong
the question is
that
can probably
because i don't believe in king affair
because it might run into some knight g5
and all the attack might come way too
quickly i mean just imagine king f8
knight g5 if you're gonna go h6 i'm
gonna go knight h7 check and oops it's
almost checkmate kind of just to
illustrate the dangers how quickly
things can escalate
and hikaru also said no no i don't want
to do any of these moves because if i do
this this is going to be just
terrible for me i have to use my chance
i have to use my momentum and bishop a4
had been played by hikaru he says just
forget about this king side i need my
counter play i need it desperately right
well bishop a4 you mentioned that you
know if white ever goes for the pawn on
c4 he gives up his light squared bishop
and then that bishop on b7 was
patrolling
that beautiful long diagonal i mean
[Music]
that was a painful decision uh
to give up the light squared bishop and
what exactly does he get in return uh
peter i mean we're assuming um
white
you know moves his queen somewhere well
maybe that's a problem
maybe he doesn't have many good squares
for his queen
queen
i don't know i guess
my guess yourself was that what he gets
in editor if he gets life
because
because believe me i mean if you are
sitting on the black side and clock is
ticking down and you also see that your
opponent has less time you feel like you
have to mess things up
and you can't go along the agenda your
opponent is hoping to to get along so in
this sense bishop a4 had to be played
and knight a for queen a4 you hit the
queen if white has to change the queens
then you say okay thank you very much
then the attack will not be so dangerous
and in end game then also for white it
will be very difficult to protect this
b2 pawn
so i'm expecting something like of a
queen move but where does this queen
move
just as you mentioned there is not so
many easy squares and some idea like
knight d5 hitting with cc and opening
things up and night jumping to bc i see
a lot of scenarios where black gets
serious counter chances
okay
so really we do have to find we do have
to be a bit careful about where
our queen might end up so
imagining peter queenie for just i i try
to avoid the queen
i think i want to keep the c1 square in
reserve
so that i have bishop e3 to c1 my bishop
on e3 was good at when when we played
bishop e3 it was a good idea it allowed
us to develop our rook we defended our
d-pawn now that our rook is developed
our bishop on e3 is kind of
well let's be frank in the way it's not
doing a lot there i'd rather see the
bishop on either jihad
that looks like an attempting square or
c1 so that was why i didn't want to play
queen c1 but okay queen e4
just for the moment
uh avoiding the trade and by the way
don't forget about the g7 pawn i very
very very much want to capture that pawn
yeah queen e4 was a very principled way
i'm pretty sure that something might
have disturbed magnus because if it's so
nice and so easy then he would have
played it i wonder maybe something like
knight d5 could be his he's worried that
i
simply hikaru gives up then the pawn on
g7 but gets kanta played with luke b2
and immediately i'm starting some luke
takes c2 knight cc check forks so we
just see how quickly things can uh get
out of control and if black gets counter
played then it really gets dangerous and
if you first repeat the bishop as you
mentioned then i have a move like cc
breaking your structure
so i think this this was the concern of
magnus
and let's not forget magnus was also
short on time so he doesn't have enough
time to to really work all these things
out so he played
much more natural luxy one it felt like
it's the professional move if you are
long time you you want to play luxi one
because you feel like after this move
i'm having things under control i don't
know if i keep serious advantage or not
if i have advantage or not but my
position is under control
however things escalated completely
because hikaru called
uh the the
the challenge i mean he took up the
challenge with knight bc he didn't want
to go into some inferior end game after
takes takes losing a lot of his
practical chances on the
what he wanted to get with counter
chances so he went night bc and magnus
did not hesitate even for a second he
opted for rook take g7x exchange
sacrifice after knight xc1 queen c1 this
is the current position we are having a
fascinating position
wow i i think that uh
our our audience and again a very big
shout out to each and every one of you
thank you for joining us and sharing uh
this exciting finals together
um
i think for
our audience peter
uh we have kind of tipped our cards and
we have
shown that we are both um
prone
to wanting to make exchange sacrifices
uh and we like these exchange sacrifices
so this
to my mind looks like a really good
exchange sacrifice because we've already
broken through on the king side
the black pawn structure even though
it's only just one pawn and a minor
piece for an exchange it's like by
taking away the g7 pawn
we made more
pawn islands in the structure and
black's pawn structure looks
absolutely
terrible
uh
now it's all about
keeping control i mean i think that
white's in pole position but can he
maintain the control and if i'm looking
right i'm seeing the move c3
nice shot by hikaru that was a tactic i
did not anticipate by the way after rook
g7
i wonder if magnus did
i'm pretty sure that he did it was also
my big concern and i wanted to mention
that
exactly as you said if white
consolidates so let's just imagine white
puts this king from e1 to g1 then one
would have the feeling that it's
strategically winning for white but of
course hikaru is not letting this happen
so he used his chance immediately with
c3 queen takes cc had to be played
knight d5 is a tempo queen c1 comes back
and now very interesting move because
one can argue that this knight on d5 is
so nice and the white bishop on e3 is
not doing that much but on the other
hand this bishop on easily might be
joining the party with bishop g5 or
bishop h6 later depending if blackview
challenged rook or not on g7 and hikaru
fed like i need to eliminate this uh
bishop and not just because i'm
eliminating it but since white is not
able to capture back with the queen
thanks to luke takes b2 right in this
case after ftx e3 it feels like the
white queen is no longer able to to join
the king side attack and combine very
dangerous threats together with the
lukon g7
exactly uh i was thinking that any king
at the eighth was going to be met by a
bishop h6 or queen h6 and that would
have just been a terrible move for
for for black so capturing even though
that that bishop on e3 doesn't look that
good it really was doing something
impacting the position and by the way i
remembered it only after a previous
broadcast a grand master from romania
michael shuba who said
bad bishops protect good pawns
it was a very insightful quote and we do
have after f takes e3 kg7 driving the
rook back
uh rook g4 on the board peter uh
i don't know i mean it's getting harder
and harder for me to assess the position
i think that this rook on b8 is terrific
i mean and
there's
queen b3 ideas that i i would
start to feel a little bit um you know
uh my king could get into danger as well
so in other words if not all play on one
goal here for white black's kicking as
well
yeah black is definitely kicking however
i do love that the white king after
knight xcc fe3 got this lovely little
squad on f2 which is a very very safe
shelter thanks to this bishop on e2
whenever black plays queen bc queen
takes b2 it's not the end of the world
because my king will have a very nice
exit on on f2 and i do see that after
all my queen on c1 is hitting the c7
pawn and if my queen hits on c7 then the
queen might join the party after all and
also combine with some look for ideas
hitting the f7 pawn white has his own
agenda so
uh very very critical moment i think
that
here black needs some super move in
order to justify that he is fine if he
fails to do that in the next one two
moves then white will just take over and
take over till the very end i believe
yeah let me just jump in really really
quickly i think that black's move is
rook g8
and why do i oh you play queen b3 just
the commentators curse the moment that
you're uh ready to say this is the right
move uh the uh the other move was going
to be played okay so i just did this uh
course for chessable you know
winning chess strategies and one of the
things that i really emphasized
in that course is this idea that you
should compare pieces
so if your opponent's rook is more
powerful or more active than europe
trade them off if your opponent's knight
is more active or more powerful than
your knight trade it off so get rid of
your opponents
active pieces let them
keep his
passive pieces and i saw this rook on g4
as being much more active than the rook
of g8 hence my suggestion to trade uh in
that line that you were looking at peter
i was thinking that if you take take
and take on c7 i take on b2
you take on e7 i go queen c2
and i was hoping that i was making
life
crazy
maybe not so crazy peter
yeah i felt like it's too much talent
yeah yeah okay
that's a great line uh for those of you
who don't know uh there was this
wonderful wonderful quote by grand
master robert huebner he was asked
about grandmaster vela merovich of
yugoslavia what do you think of that guy
and robert hoopner said too much talent
sometimes you overdo it a little bit
and uh that did not happen tell us what
happened instead uh in that moment where
i thought rook g8
he went queen b3 uh peter we'll just go
back and catch it very quickly yeah
actually hikaru used all your ideas but
i think he did it uh very precisely okay
i mean this is actually their job no i
mean that's why they are playing the
final to be super precise they're very
deserving yes yeah so queen b3 queen
takes c7 queen takes b2 magnus played
king f2 i mean very very natural i saw
that the engine bar jumped after this
that engine was not sure that king f2 is
the best move but it's so natural and
with one minute on the clock a little
bit more than one minute believe me any
super player just wants to make sure
that he gets this king f2 in and after
he sees what's going to happen however
he could use this moment for queen b7
stabilizing getting rid of this queen
from c7 the queen moved to a5 and he can
immediately use your id of luke g8
perfect timing now because
i mean queen takes c7 will not do such
damage anymore so rook f4 played of
course white has to keep the rooks alive
because after all this pawn on f7 is is
weak but black with his own rook on g8
putting pressure on the g2 pawn the
queen on the long diagonal hitting g2 as
well it
it it shows that the position is very
double-edged and after look for queen c6
queen d2 h6 happened magnus down to 41
second on the clock dramatic
wow
very very dramatic indeed and
how
which side do you prefer peter who who's
got the easier game to begin with and do
you feel
the game is
roughly a balance or is there one side
that you definitely
prefer
i think that the game is very much out
of control and uh because it's out of
control i i perfectly understand
magnus's choice queen dc was a actually
hinting towards h7 so queen h7 is almost
like a deadly threat luke g7 a very nice
way to to consolidate the the king side
also black can play for example king g8
in the future so magnus has no attack
going on the king side so he prefers to
collect the material but after
collecting the material it feels like
okay you exchanged the queens and this
is what we have seen queen takes a6
bishop a6 look b2 check bishop e2 played
bishop takes a3
g4
okay maybe white is a little bit better
but given the clock situation and also
by knowing how the players got here
i assume that
draw is the most probable result here
exactly we have a material imbalance
of a knight and two pawns
for rook
uh the rook on g7 is a little bit
awkward but you can always play rook g8
king g7 in it and activate
if black were able to put both rooks
on the the second rank and keep that
bishop on e2 in a pin i mean hikaru
would definitely be thinking that i'm
the one
with the better chances at the moment i
guess it's coming down to
uh
it
is the idea of e4 and d5 dangerous for
black uh peter in your in your in your
view
no i don't think so because if you go e4
d5 then suddenly my dark squad bishop
with a timely bishop c5 check can cause
a lot of damage also white spawns are i
mean pieces are really pegged uh
the problem is everything is perfect
everything is placed perfectly but what
to do with them and magnus goes lookie
for
rook g8 look for basically indicating
that yeah i don't know what to do
hikaru goes king g7 and already the
ideas that you mentioned rookie 8
doubling the rook
on the second is an agenda so magnus
goes g5 finally after the black king
went to g7 white
could get rid of his uh problems with
these g4 h4 problems a g5 knight g5
and i think magnus is in in control i
mean control means that he has draw in
his pocket i don't believe that right i
mean black has any winning chances and i
wonder whether
hikaru
chose quick quick quickly
quickly let me interrupt w why after
bishop takes pawn takes rook h8
peter i've got the threat of rook h2 you
sure
there's control i mean exactly at the
moment when i saw that white has
everything under control i also noticed
that yeah duke h2 is a very
very nasty threat but still i believe
that if i
get out without losing
big time mate but
wasn't part of the plan
rook takes e3 and oops
no no no
this this would be uh oh hold on this is
the game sorry i thought we were the
analysis i'm sorry
oh well this is completely
busted i mean
magnus uh
it's king is terrible and he's probably
just going to lose the d4 pawn as well
rookie 3d3 is on on icaru's agenda
something happened uh
i thought that
a well-played draw was in the offing
but i think g5 was mis-timed uh peter
well i think that this whole rookie for
look f4 or maybe jeff i i don't know
what magnus has had missed or maybe he
was just simply done to this 10 seconds
and okay with 10 seconds on the clock
playing this position was very difficult
i thought that maybe just giving up with
g5 the pawn and going for these three
versus to exchange them was a relatively
safe way to make a draw but maybe it
wasn't so safe at at least while playing
your game you have this impression that
it's it's tough then you don't want to
go for it
and after you might regret it and by now
for sure magnus is regretting because i
mean what we are seeing here is uh
ed3 d5 played
in fact
could have
could have black played the move look d4
i think that that would have been uh a
you know a winning one so to speak it's
not checkmate but take the rooks off the
board when the pawn
i i think it's just it's just
winning and i'm looking at the faces of
the players on uh
the cameras and again i mean magnus just
he he has remarkable calm
and sometimes it's really hard to
to tell
if magnus
is winning or losing uh hikaru wears his
emotions on his sleeve you know like
openly but i'm looking at icaru and i'm
seeing a man of great confidence there
and finally i'm seeing uh magnus step
back and just kind of saying oh man did
i blow this uh peter this is terrible
yeah i mean i think there are zero
chances to survive and
and yeah maybe magnus is khan because he
already knows that there is no reason to
be
nervous
to be nervous yeah because you are
nervous when you still feel that you
have chance but if you know you have no
chance then you are already kind of
settling in and you are very angry with
yourself but also during the game you
should not be angry at yourself because
that takes away your focus so magnus
goes for e6 but this is already some
desperate attempt exactly and by the way
the bishop could not have moved there
was a rook h3 checkmate in the position
so
magnus was running out of moves and that
was why he played the move e6
okay but now
he's upon down
as well as an exchange
and it's just getting worse and worse uh
peter
yeah there are just no chances the
problem is that divides bishop on fc is
not participating so if
right at least for example would be
given this check on g6 and after king f7
could move his fc bishop to f6 then
there would be something to discuss
because white has suddenly some counter
play but with a bishop fc and also the
king cut on along the h file this looks
just uh completely lost
uh could can uh magnus try to finagle
his king up the h file maybe on a really
really good day somehow get bishop h5
and g6 in uh
not i mean it's rook h4
that's terrible um
sorry i
i i don't have a good
in a bad position it's hard to make good
suggestions peter
yeah i mean it will be eight played also
very nice
let's not forget that this
there is a pawn on d5
and magnus played look for in order to
stop stop it advancing to to d4
but okay
it played
luke takes f8 played
g6
i'm expecting resignation any time
in this exactly
g8 would be a good start yeah towards
the resignation factor
and now
isn't it time to make a queen d4
yeah but i mean i like hikaru's movie
one very much because basically it means
that i paralyze your bishop you can
never move the bishop and whenever you
move the bishop i can just hunt it down
sacrifice it and the king and pawn
ending is completely winning agree this
is something you really want to do with
little time on the clock and also it's
enough arguments for your opponent not
really to continue the fight anymore
right yeah and he and hikaru one magnus
has just designed after rookie one wow
very very impressive going into this
match
tanya
had interviewed hikaru and hikaru had
you know compared them and he said well
like i'm really good here and i'm really
good there and i do this very well and i
defend very well unfortunately there's
one magnus carlson that tends to do all
the things i do very well just a little
bit better
this game
tanya
uh icaru did everything a little bit
better than magnus what did magnus do
wrong
did we miss something it just
wow
yes magnus played for the initiative and
managed to get that even though he was
down in exchange it was an extremely
interesting battle on the board but it
all fell apart when he went king f2 and
hikaru really did not give him a chance
after that brilliant play by hikaru
nakamura so far and hikaru draws first
blood and
leads the first set
with one and a half to magnus playing
catch up right now in the finals
we're gonna be going into a break but
before that some good news a big shout
out to grand master pen tala hari
krishna for his contribution to kiva's
cause hari very generously has donated 1
000 euros in premium membership and
these memberships will be given out to
chess clubs in india kids and chess
clubs in india uh thank you hari for
your support supporting chess as well as
supporting the community with your uh
with the memberships that you have
bought for the young talents in india
we're going to go into a short break
check out this amazing magnus trailer
about his amazing the magnus touch end
game course and we'll be back with a
very special guest
ladies and gentlemen please take your
seats
the show is about to begin
[Music]
and you still seem kind of upset about
that inaccuracy yeah nine years later
yeah
which is why
whenever this game is brought up
[Music]
[Music]
you look at farmers in the rural areas
of tanzania and uganda the way that they
farm is very manual labor intensive and
they can't afford to buy equipment
outright and so we're focused on raising
the level of income by selling
productive use equipment with financing
[Music]
[Music]
people
foreign
yes
[Music]
what
[Music]
lady
chess 24 did an amazing response to the
pandemic by setting up this brilliant
magnus carlsen chester which has been
such a big boon and such a such a
delightful event and a tour for all of
us in a very difficult time and now it
comes a full circle as chess 24 supports
kiva's pledge of raising 50 million
dollars to help serve
isolated businesses and underserved
communities and uh
all of you with your generous
contribution by going premium for
yourself or for your friends has been
has been such a big part of it so big
shout out to all of you for that we've
seen grandmasters do it we've seen our
non-premium members go mem
go premium
and to talk more about the change that
chess can bring
in partnership with kiva and how chess
impacts the community i am delighted to
be joined by enrique saboya vice
president of growth at kiva
hi enrique
hi tanya thank you for having me it's
great to be here
uh you know enrique we've been talking
so much about kiva and the wonderful
incredible work that you do and just the
chess community is so excited to be part
of this course and i want i have so many
questions about kiva but before that i
think my first question has to be who
are you rooting for in this epic final
that we are witnessing right now
tanya that's a that's a great question i
have to say this this may be a boring
question because his name is on the
tournament but i'm a big magnus fan um
now i know he just said a little uh uh
that the last the last match was a rough
one for him but but i am hopeful that he
he can come back but i i got magnus
going all the way
all right well i'm sure you're not alone
in that uh but enrique it's gonna be a
it's gonna be a very very epic final and
of course talking about comebacks that's
what i think 2020 is about just uh this
ridiculously challenging and difficult
year that we've had
and how chess has impacted our lives
during this pandemic and how kiva has
come forward to give back to the
community and to support businesses and
help them survive
we've had amazing contributions enrique
by grand masters we've had hari krishna
you've had grand master peter lecko
contribute with premium membership
we've had vasa levant chip 10
by magnus carlson his prize money will
be donated to the to this cause
tell us how does kiba work how is it
that you scout the businesses that you
choose to support
yeah let me tell let me let me say a few
things about how cuba works
uh kiva kiva is a 15 year old um tack
first uh nonprofit right that really
combined for the first time 15 years ago
when the internet was in its infancy the
ability to microfund and
uh funds for people who are financially
excluded in the world
there are we we estimate there's about
1.7 billion people still in the world
who don't have access to financial
markets to improve their lives whether
that is to start a business whether that
is to get an education or to simply
build plumbing in their homes they don't
have the access to the capital to do
that
and we um our founders 15 years ago
discover that with very little money we
could change people's lives all over the
world and that we didn't need we didn't
need a bank we need to go through the
regular process of financing we can
actually ask people to
give
twenty five dollars fifty dollars a
hundred dollars and if we pull those
together we can help an entrepreneur in
kenya start a farming business
we can help a student in thailand get
her education uh or we can we we could
help a mother um in another in
in lebanon uh build plumbing and they're
in her home for the first time so that's
that's the impetus behind kiva cuba has
a number of initiatives like eva capital
kiva protocol all in the name of
financial inclusion but what we're
really known for is the kiva.org
marketplace where on any given day you
can find thousands of people whom you
can help directly and what's really
unique is that you know there's so many
ways to help
people around the world you can
volunteer your time you can donate to an
organization but what's unique about
kiva is that kiva you can choose
directly whom you're helping right so
you can see the person you're supporting
you can follow along their journey how
their business is going um that you can
get updates from from the impact of your
contribution and third because it's a
loan and not just a donation
with a 90 historically our kiva loans
have had a 97 percent payback you you
can expect to get a large percentage of
that money back and then help someone
else so that contribution actually goes
much further and we work with hundreds
of organizations around the world and we
work directly with with with
entrepreneurs as well to source those
people to source those businesses and in
vet obviously we have a we have a we
have a very very in-depth process to
to vet the people who we put on our
platform and then follow through their
journey and provide other types of
support
for them to be successful um we've
helped over 3 million people in 15 years
we've raised almost 1.5 billion dollars
in 15 years um and and that you know
we're in a moment where that help has
never been more needed as a response to
code big 19. so we couldn't be more
excited about this partnership uh with
chess 24 and the tournament
uh to help the recovery in the relief in
in the middle of covet 19 uh pandemic
that's really fascinating to hear
enrique and the one thing that really
struck me was the fact that uh
contributors and lenders can actually
see how and where the money's been used
and the entire journey of the business
or the individual that they're
supporting
that's exactly right we have i mean as i
said we're always helping thousands of
people in a given point and those
borrowers have and and and our partners
on the field have access to a platform
where they can provide an update hey
that that cow they said they needed
those 500
to buy so they could increase their
milking
capabilities for their business
we the co the cow just arrived and our
production has doubled and so forth so
we can we can really follow um along the
impact of your contribution which is
such a unique and rewarding way to wait
to give and to do good around the world
100 and like you said that it's uh never
been needed like it is right now uh also
you mentioned a very high percentage of
the payback on this on these micro
credits that you do do you think that
as opposed to let's say charity giving
out micro loans also builds up
accountability and responsibility to for
the borrower and to actually put in that
effort and go that extra mile to set up
whatever it is that a lender has given
the money out for
that's the theory uh and we in what
we've seen in practice and and by the
way charity is incredibly important as
well and to help people in places in
poverty and difficult situations we
really need a full system of support
but we do believe
us lending and loans do play an
important role in building a very
sustainable way to lift people out of
poverty um and and we have seen that
played out uh and in this moment in 2020
we are really staring in the face of
potentially decades of progress we've
seen
be
be taken back right as we struggle to
come out of this moment so our mission
is really to
help how do we how do we make sure that
we we we slow down any regression to to
position we were before
the last 20 to 30 years of progress
against poverty kiva and other
incredible organizations around the
world have made
and make sure that the people who are
already in the in in the hardest
positions are
have an opportunity to
to thrive again as we as we come out of
the pandemic
you know it also just this incredible
work that you're doing and how you are
contributing to also
you know the the accountability and
responsibility of setting up the
business helping them and then also
these individuals being
through the track record of kiva of
being able to actually pay back it
speaks really highly about the
effectiveness of uh micro lending why
why do you think that micro lending is
uh is so effective
uh that's a great question i think um i
mean it's really what's fascinating
about what kiva has been able to prove
is that the traditional financial
markets have
not appropriately
determined the risk of those borrowers
right the reason they don't have access
to financial markets a lot of the time
is that the financial markets have
decided they are not we don't expect
them to be reliable borrowers and what
we've been able to show is that um they
are right 97 that's higher than a
repayment rate in most banks around the
world
97 of every dollar that we've ever lent
out into the field
is is paid back and that's incredible
and we're incredibly proud of the
platform we've built and incredibly
proud of our borrowers and our partners
who made it possible um i think what's
what's uh what uh what is one of the
things that make it possible is that
we're really talking about
microfinancing right banks in in in
large organizations are not interested
in getting a loan of 100 500 700 maybe a
thousand dollars to someone their
overhead their cost structure doesn't
support that
kiva because the way word structure does
a non-profit allows us to do that and
allows us to do it to do that in a way
that we can do it at scale so and we can
do very quickly right we can get money
in the hands of people who need it when
they need it so that those are some of
the some of the factors that make
microfinancing kiva so successful
that's incredible to hear and uh you
know it also reminds me enrique off
of nobel prize winner dr mohammad yunus
and his work with grameen bank in from
the part of the world that i come from
it was in bangladesh that he started
this to help out uh individuals and from
very poor backgrounds
is the model that self-sustaining model
where you actually provide even business
inputs to to your borrowers is is it
similar to that model
we do we have we have a number of
experimentations that we run in
different parts of the world right for
example in the us we partner with
um with what we call center hubs in 20
different cities to help underserved
communities where there are additional
services that keva borrowers have access
to so we are always experimenting with
ways to provide additional services um
to to our borrower so that we can set
them up to be most successful
a big congratulations and so much
respect for the work you do we do have
liftoff but i cannot let you go without
asking a final question which is that
how how does kiva see chess fitting into
this uh this aim that kiva has and this
cause that it supports how did the
partnership between the magnus carlson
chester and kiva come to be
well um i have to give a shout out to
david and sebastian from the chess24
group who reached out and said hey we
love what you guys are doing we love how
strategically you are we love how long
term thinking
kiva is to set up people um sustainably
out of poverty and we think there are a
lot of a lot of things that are similar
to how people think about chess and how
chess players think about the next move
um so we were really inspired by that in
the ability for us to do something
together so i i i'm so proud of this
partnership and the help that we're
getting from so many grandmasters from
so many chess 24 subscribers to help us
get to 50 million dollars so that we can
help the next million people uh be able
to
make it through this difficult time
and and recover and rebuild as we come
out of uh of the kobe 19 pandemic
thank you so much enrique and you're
absolutely right that chess is all about
overcoming challenges challenges and as
a sport it breaks all barriers and that
fits in line perfectly with kiwa's
philosophy of inclusivity in the final
as far as finances are concerned and in
the financial world uh thank you so much
for joining us
thank you tanya thank you for having me
this has been wonderful and i'll be
watching
[Music]
thank you and uh yes with that uh we've
got action on the board so without
further ado let's bring on yas and peter
to fill to fill us in with what's going
on
well thank you very much tanya indeed we
do have liftoff in this the second game
and as we get ready for the second game
and uh peter taking us through the
opening moves i also want to uh welcome
john urschel for those of you don't know
john urschel
was an nfl national football league
player in american sport football our
most popular sport
he's getting his uh phd
in
in mathematics and he loves chess and
he's a good friend john welcome to our
show
yes sir how's it going how are you going
good
how are you surviving the pandemic
yourself oh i'm doing all right you know
we're making here what about you
but
yeah a little uh pandemic fatigue i want
to say uh how's your chest great because
you're going to be forced to comment on
this finals
oh yeah this is uh i'm not sure this is
the ideal game for me to comment this
looks like quite a crazy night orphan
yes or you know me i don't uh yeah you
don't touch this with either color so
i'm very good very good uh
very good of you john not to do that but
peter
let's get uh from the start just the the
players repeated
game one up to bishop h4 but then
there was a big
uh diversion peter
yeah thanks jose hi john very nice to
have you here you know you are not the
only one who doesn't really understand
what's going on because it's
such a sharp and crazy position but one
thing i have to say that this this
format is just brilliant i mean look at
this and this is a very nice
illustration what the players are going
over with this format because they have
just finished another dramatic game but
they are entering another very very
crucial and very sharp battle where they
have to be prepared they have to be
ready and shout out to their teams
because in order to be able to go into
all these sharp variations
they have to get the ideas they have to
get the directions from their team and
i'm pretty sure that both teams had been
heavily working on for this game mostly
of course
nakamura's team hikarus team was
asked because you are you have divide
pieces and if the world champion magnus
casting is ready to repeat the valuation
this somewhat strange looking bishop h
for check bishop e7 it means that he was
happy with the first game's opening
outcome and hikaru says no thank you i
want to go along a completely new new
path with knight a5 but the indication
of the players that they have been
blitzing out the next moves it was clear
that also magnus had anticipated this
turn of events with knight a5 knight d7
the move that comes
here this a4 move this means that there
is some really deep preparation involved
because this is certainly not a move
that you can even consider without
preparation
what is this move all about well i don't
think we have the time to to get into
all the finesses but let's see what
happened magnus castles knight xb7 queen
b8 knight a5 queen takes b2 rook c1
played and it was the first time magnus
really took his time and played the move
look f f8 to c8
wow well
normally speaking uh peter you don't go
down the board capture a pawn on b7
and lose and return the pawn on b2 but
in this case
uh hikaru has won the crucial
c6 square
and from a strategic point of view
that's a great victory for white
yeah that's that's the whole essence of
the position
but on the other hand black also got a
lot of activity so
it's very very hard to judge
without
exact preparation what is happening
because if we don't rely on our feelings
and we see a knight on c6 and we just
imagine for example white castling short
and then playing some move like c4
stabilizing the position we see a lot of
arguments why white should be better but
on the other hand also let's not forget
that black has this lovely square c5 for
the future because the b pawn from white
had been eliminated so yes white got a
very nice pawn uh very nice square on c6
for his knight but on the other hand
black also has a lot of dynamics now the
move bishop f6 also highlights that
black has some very nice bishops here
ready to
join the action if if the position gets
opened
wow
cool double edged position okay now
having set the table so nicely for us
uh peter
what do you think of the move
c2 c4
and basically offering a queen trait and
i wanted to recapture with my king
yeah and c4 on the board
[Music]
well john as you know and i get in this
cheapo once once a broadcast these guys
are really good
they anticipate our suggestions
clearly i'm uh i'm still sort of
parsing all the moves that have happened
i have to say that sort of early on this
g3 is still sort of a strange
move to me as sort of a patzer like this
uh
this bishop sort of inducing g3 and then
going back exactly it's sort of still
strange to me and i'm still sort of
figuring out what's going on here just
john
i i
seriously i i mean i i'm an
international grand master and sometimes
i think well maybe they should take away
my title because you know you used to
tempi in the opening just to induce one
little pawn weakness and really uh
you know this is
you know preparation at a super
extremely high level because i have the
same doubts
and feelings uh as yourself about that
particular play what makes it very
interesting is what peter was saying a
moment ago the players have actually
reached that position in game one a game
by the way that was drawn those of you
who are just catching up late shame on
you to begin with second
he caro leads
uh i'm still coming to terms with that
myself peter because it happened also
very quickly
a game that was in balance for quite
some time we hadn't expected a carl to
win he did win
which means that he has a one and a half
half lead going into this game as we
know they play four games to set of four
games first player to two and a half
wins the set wins the day hikaru wins
this game he's won the first set peter
yeah absolutely i mean i believe that uh
magnus did everything right in the first
two games because i think he really
played high clever very high quality
chess the only problem was with the
clock and uh he has to make sure that he
handles the clock better because hika is
such a resourceful player so
you don't want to get a massive position
and one minute on the clock against
hikaru because then you know exactly
that things can happen just as they
happened and
i believe that most of the part of that
game uh game two which hikar won
actually magnus was in control but he
lost control because of the time issue
and he has to speed up
because if he if he is little bit slow
and too hesitant then
things like
happened in the game too can happen
again and this is not what magnus or his
fans wants to see
exactly now john i mean you're just
starting your chess career
you you understand
it isn't an easy uh road ahead
and as you watch this final and you
watch the games unfold certain moves man
they're instinctive they you you get you
understand
that yeah this knight on c6 is a is a
monster uh other
other moves really cause you a lot of
self-doubt clear
fair enough
in chess for yourself what has been your
most difficult challenge uh
is it in games is it tactics is it
middle games you can't say all of those
yes sir
you you gotta pick
what you have
difficulties
well you uh you already took my desired
answer but i would say that something
that uh i think comes intuitively to a
lot of people that doesn't come so
easily for me
is being able to understand the sort of
give and take and balance between
sort of material and sort of static
advantages versus the possibility of
sort of
a strong dynamic initiative
for let's say giving material or giving
some structural weakness this is
something
that i feel like i'm still not quite
great at evaluating
wow wait a minute well first of all
that's not a beginner's answer john that
is a very sophisticated answer because
even when i was becoming a chess grad
master i was still having difficulties
understanding those transitions between
you know giving material and it's being
a static position versus
a dynamic
imbalance um
but you're
you're okay as far as tactics are
concerned
you're developing a nose for tactics are
you
i feel like i'm improving i i have to
say that i do try to do sort of tactics
trainer fairly regularly and i think
for things such as that just repetition
actually helps a lot like i've noticed
that uh if i do let's say
you know two hours of tactics a week
i get better you know as the weeks
progress and you know i'm better at
tactics this year than i was last year
and so i would say
that's sort of a very natural thing you
see more examples you come to recognize
different concepts and then you sort of
work on your ability to sort of
concretely calculate sort of the
tactical themes that
you start to recognize because you've
sort of seen these ideas more and more
all right well thank you we have a move
do feel free to interrupt peter i at any
time you like and say guys i got a
question uh peter we have an answer to
the move c2 c4 uh magnus decided he
didn't want to trade queens
yeah that's not a big surprise
because yeah in the end game of course
white's knight on c6 would be
way too much of a factor
first of all yes the knight on c6 is
wonderful but we should not forget about
the simple fact that there is the option
for black to challenge this knight with
the move knight b8
and uh
and it's not so easy to answer it i mean
it's clear that you're gonna go knight
a5 but then i sidestep with the queen
and then uh after all thanks to this
bishop on f5 and controlling the
diagonal
h7 b1 diagonal i have uh b1 square under
control so just playing some loop b1
getting control of the b file is not
possible
uh another thing a more desperate and
drastical measure would be some action
sacrifice on c6 which in some position
would come into consideration but here i
feel like it shouldn't be really an
uh an issue because uh simply let's
suppose white castles
and if black really goes along this
sacrifice pat then white has a very nice
way of
dealing with it with a move like queen
d5 forcing the exchange of queens and
black is just not in time to get his
really nice counter play and
compensation with knight c5 going so i
believe after short castle the question
is what happens after knight b8
forcing what you said a kind of a night
retreat
knight to a5
tickling the queen
um as we go down this path and it's not
that clear you know who benefits the
most again i'm seeing that bishop on f5
uh
peter and i'm saying that bishop is
actually too strong
i'd rather get rid of it we saw in game
one that hikaru played bishop d3 and
there was a bishop h3 answer could we go
back to the position before castles
and let me ask you
i would like to get rid of the light
squared bishop so i could win control
over the b1 square
with bishop d3 right yes
yeah but it's also a very scary move
yeah because if i play bishop hc you're
not gonna castle in this
in this game
right so bishop h3 rook b1 queen c7
wow that's a kind of a tough middle game
because it looks like black's queen like
lex queen side
like as if the entire queenside board is
paralyzed i mean okay i play king f2
you're right i can't castle but
at such a cost uh black's pieces all
gummied up
you know what jose since you are not
impressed let me play a different way
okay
yeah after bishop dci take take and play
knight b8 ah
and my intended rook b1 of course yeah
then i'm gonna go queen d7 and eyeing
this a4 pawn ah
nice
okay that
that looks like a great answer that
looks
that looks very very convincing
okay
thank you peter i'm satisfied
you make me happy i'm happy yeah
yeah
and and by the way john uh i don't know
if you were
with us when henrique of kiba
was being interviewed by tanya and that
was one of the things that uh i missed
about the world of chats that we that
that there wasn't more
of a charity uh program for the chess
players like we couldn't channel our
energies and helping others whether it
be children's hospitals there's an
enormous need as we both
as we all know and the pandemic has
really made it even more so uh but kiva
is quite a unique organization kind of
cool i like this whole
microloaning uh
ideas what about you what's your take
no no i think it
seems like a fantastic idea i think that
uh
it's good that um sort of small
businesses and sort of
small companies have the opportunity to
sort of take advantage of loans because
this is sort of a fundamental sort of
concept in business the ability to sort
of
you know leverage the assets you have so
that you can sort of
have more uh
i don't know more um resources i think
it's you know it's important it's
important for growth and
you know
places where people don't have access to
things like this they're definitely at a
severe disadvantage so
it's exactly a totally unserved
uh
large segment of our global population
and henrique made it very clear that if
i'm jp morgan bank
uh i'm not set up to make
a 500 loan i want to make a 50 000 loan
uh
because of all the time that my
employees will give in approving that
loan so these
micro loans you know just totally
unserved in our banking
community banking area and if you don't
have credit i mean how are you going to
start a business
so
i'm very enthusiastic myself i think
it's a it's a really cool concept and
i'm so happy that chess players uh
peter again a thank you big shout out to
you and we just saw their uh
more grand masters including hari
krishna
pledged their support so it's all good
it's all good
[Music]
this position has gotten really
interesting this
idea i was trying to figure out how you
sort of deal with this threat of e4 this
g4 is interesting
yeah peter
as i as i was uh talking i wanted to
stop myself and say hey wait a minute i
mean g4
uh
changed completely
uh the concepts in the position please
peter
yeah it changed but already many things
changed yeah also magnus switching back
with rookie 8 but before we get into the
details of the possession let me just
say how much i love the way john puts
his his head into the monitor i mean i'm
seeing here on the zoom call that
you are fully focused and so excited and
it's so nice to see this because this is
exactly the attitude that you need if
you want to improve in chess because
without this you know you don't go
anywhere but i just love it i just see
that your heart is into it and this is
the way and i'm very happy for it
i appreciate that thank you
okay so coming back to the game yeah
after looking eight basically hikaru
said that yes i have this lovely knight
on c6 but since i'm not able to play
rook b1
i would love to make the most use of my
knight on c6 and what usually we are
taught when you have the space advantage
it gives you the chance of trying to
play on both flanks and uh by playing g4
and let's let's look at the next moves
because not just g4 after bishop g6
white expanded with g4 g5 kicking back
the bishop from f6 from its very nice
post to d8 black just give him one move
goes bishop b6 and is very happy but
hikaru says no no my friend i'm just in
time to lock you down with a4 a5 where
this bishop from d8 gonna go because i
have everything under control so
maybe maybe magnus in trouble
yeah it seems that white is trying to
get a
what we would call in seattle circles a
big grip
uh
locking down black's pieces everywhere
and by the way i was just about to say
while i'm saying all of this i mean i'm
looking at that night peter
john and i'm just saying you gotta go
that night
is out of here i don't care i'm
sacrificing exchange or i'm playing
knight v8 but that knife is dominant
it's got to go i like this move rook c8
a lot
yeah it had to be played i mean black
really did not really have an
alternative i mean it looks eight yeah
preparing knight b8 slippering somewhere
maybe the exchange sacrifice but also
one other worrying that magnus is again
way behind on the clock he's down to a
little bit more than five minutes versus
hikaru's 10
and uh
yeah this is this is not a nice combo i
mean being under pressure and being done
on the clock against hikaru this is
exactly the nightmare scenario exactly
john how how do you handle time time
trouble uh
the does it
it does it very poorly
very poorly i have to say that i'm
someone who you know i like to take my
time i like to sort of think and
understand a position before i make a
move and so
i can say that i've made uh
many many a silly blunders and sort of
you know short time pressure i i'm not a
big fan of you know bullet or blitz i
like you know rapid
well as uh as our friend maurice ashley
likes to say
time trouble makes a fool
out of us all and still uh by the way
peter
i mean the players are coming up with
some
really incredibly important strategic
motifs you know bishop d3
uh
inviting e5 e4 and all kinds of things
going on there and then very quickly
came the move knight f8 and then very
quickly came the response bishop e4
these are very tough decisions that they
are just snapping right out
yeah i think in magnus case it's very
logical because he has to speed up and
this is kind of the last moment when he
can speed up i mean if he goes down to
three minutes it will be very crucial
but on the other hand if he is able to
handle this uh situation not quickly
then
he at least gets less pressure from the
clock but
the point is that knight feet and queen
d7 were the two nice natural looking
moves because they both made perfect
sense the knight is coming to g6
supporting the bishop and if the bishops
are exchanged and the knight lands on g6
pinon b7 was doing nothing so playing
queen d7 was also very natural but now
what next and the move king h1 is
typically the move that you just love to
make with the white pieces because it's
a very nice stabilizing move and you
give black the move please show me what
you got because it's not so obvious and
magnus came up with a very nice resource
h5h4 first of all that's worse because
there were almost practically no other
legal moves in the position and h5h4
still improves his position a little bit
okay i like the move king h1 very much
prophylactic move getting out of the way
of any queen g4 checks or queen h3s
h5h4 i i can imagine another
prophylactic move like rook g1 here as
well for white
it's just you know and again i'm looking
at this knight on c6 and i'm just
thinking to myself again and again this
knight is so powerful uh
that that that black needs to do
something before white plays a move like
bishop b6 and maybe forces material
advantage so i do feel like that icaru
is definitely for choice
um
and uh well again and again uh the time
is a factor but the
just the score of the match a win
and the set is clinched by hikaru john i
just wanted to ask you a little bit too
talk talk to our audience a little bit
about your transition from football
player to a
math
phd
to
chess fan
and to pandemic how do all of these
things
intersect and have impacted your life i
know you're
a daddy too by the way yeah yeah no my
wife and i we have a little two-year-old
so uh during the pandemic we're
you know we're getting lots of time with
her she's you know stuck in the house so
she's a little you know more anxious
than usual but uh but yes no i'm uh as
uh
some of the audience might know i'm a
former uh professional football player
american football
and i would say that uh these days i
live a much a much quieter life i mean
you know i used to sort of bang heads
with people sort of many times on a
daily basis for a living and
at the same time i was trying to get my
phd in math at mit i was sort of doing
the phd while playing pro football at
the same time and
i have to say now that i'm retired and
focusing just on math and sort of
fatherhood it's uh it's much less
stressful it's very uh it's a very calm
easy life so i'm i'm enjoying my
retirement
good and in terms of the pandemic you
talk about mit are you
learning remotely so to speak are your
classes online and uh certainly your
chess is online you can't go to the club
so talk a little bit about that
yeah it's uh it's really an interesting
time for education in general i have to
say uh mit has been completely shut down
so no one is going into the office
uh i'm very i'm in the last year of my
phd so i'm not taking courses i'm
performing research but uh
i have to say that it has really
disrupted academia and i feel that
universities in general are quite
quite concerned about sort of the
effects of the pandemic on sort of the
uh
the american university system the
american university system is quite
different than sort of
what you see let's say in europe
yeah
it's a very financially driven system
and so yeah
and in school learning is a very big
issue sorry i should have mentioned it's
massachusetts
institute of technology one of the
really really really tough top top top
universities
in the united states that john uh
wants to attend is attending and is
doing this research because again as he
says uh universities are shut down and
that's really impactful too john uh
america has students from all over the
world and they're impacted because man
they can't even go on campus anymore
i know it's uh it's a it's a tough time
for education we'll see sort of how
things go i am very pleased that uh sort
of at least our sort of international
students will be able to stay in the
united states for people who uh weren't
up to speed on some of the drama about a
month ago
we're all sort of very happy in academia
that we can keep our international
students
even though they won't be sort of
studying in person because these people
they're really
sort of
in some ways this is part of like what
makes sort of the america the american
education system great that we sort of
we have brilliant researchers and
brilliant thinkers from all over the
world all sort of in one place it's
there's something nice about that oh
it's wonderful sorry peter uh tell us uh
bring us up to date with what has
happened i see a queen landed on h3 and
i see a rook
slid nicely over to the open b file
well i think what is happening is that
magnus is desperately trying to find
some counter play but there is no
counter play and that's the reason why
he hasn't been moving for now more than
three minutes uh what to do i mean white
has
everything under control the only thing
he has to watch out but of course he's
clearly watching out that after bishop
takes e4 not to run into the
chipolito trick with bishop g5 because
all of a sudden
uh black would
win material and get out of the box but
of course white captures back with the
queen
and having things completely under
control and going down under two minutes
magnus fed like all these things like
i don't want to exchange the bishop
because this is strategically lost he
goes for a move bishop h5 this is like a
desperado i mean i feel like this move
should not work on the other hand i
perfectly understand why magnus does it
because he wants to mess things up he
understands that he's in trouble and
he just doesn't want to sit and wait
yeah i was going to say you you
mentioned it very well what are the
alternatives uh give the suggestion
and at least in this case uh you've got
some kinds you you you're keeping the
pieces obviously bishop f5 would be a
terrible reaction because of bishop
takes f3 whoops
so not to do that but i'm now i'm
actually thinking some rook f2 and maybe
rook
you know i i to keep in reserve queen f1
as a potential defense as well just to
drive the queen back and the fact that
you know white has so many positional
trumps center queenside
uh just don't blunder your king
yeah but hang on look at this what is
happening now hikaru played the move
bishop b6 a very forcing move because
he's threatening bishop f5 not at the
queen protects on fc magnus took bishop
to g5 and now basically this means that
bishop f5 is the planned move however
does black have the contest like e5 e4
right
oh
this almost looks like a blunder wait a
minute what bishop
bishop takes g5 bishop f5 e4
i have to take the queen you take my
queen but
now suddenly
i take the rook but this past spawn on
d3 i mean a lot of whoa
uh
on the one hand a moment ago
white looked dominate
like he was dominating
this looks chaotic i i i'm not a fan
of
of hikaru's choice um
peter
yeah it's again i mean objectively maybe
this is fine on the other hand i'm
pretty sure that this is exactly the
scenario of what magnus was dreaming of
because he if he gets counter played and
the clock situation is not as dramatic
as it is if he is stuck with a position
where he simply doesn't know which move
to make
so
maybe it's good for white but
at least gives practical chances to
magnus
well absolutely uh practical chances
indeed and after bishop takes g5 if i if
i'm looking at the player's right uh
hikaru has been slow to react i just
want to put it like that normally
speaking you know john when you make a
sacrifice man you want to follow up to
say like yeah you see this is
i'm boss this is why i made the
sacrifice you make the sacrifice and
then you stop
your opponent says
dude i guess that was a blunder huh
[Music]
bishop f5 on the board
by the way there was an alternative to
e4 and magnus said i also have bishop g6
wow
which
really it does make a lot more sense
because
now at the instead of having a pawn on
d3 you got a bishop on d3 which is
forking two rooks uh peter
yeah i mean i did not even imagine that
such a good scenario could be
could be available for black i was
already happy about this e5 e4 because i
was just so happy that i managed to
create something
in fact black is winning back the
exchange right
but hikaru played the move bishop ec
this is what
he relies on did he expect did he
anticipate this
whatever in any case a striking move but
what i'm wondering that anyway the look
is not i mean the looks are not running
away
exactly
and ikaru's trick is that bishop takes
e3 walks into a knight
e7 check even here i'm not completely
convinced that the knight is great on c8
but okay it does in any case win an
exchange so that was the reason for
bishop e3 black is under no obligation
to capture the bishop he can move his
bishop away bishop f6 as you're
indicating peter uh looks perfectly
reasonable as you say that the rooks on
on b1 and f1 are are uh still under
attack
yeah look fc one being played
so the point is that actually now black
is a pawn up however in this end game
the knight on c6 is so dominant that i
even don't really feel like this pawn is
so important and magnus also taking a
little bit his time before capturing
this look on b1 because his bishop on
this is such a powerful piece creating
some counter play
right it's not even obvious if you have
to take this look or not
exactly i think that there's a
a good
case to be made for the move e5 e4 that
bishop on f6
is currently behind the pawn on e5 so
move like e4
even if white plays for example rook b6
and manages to save an exchange maybe
this is the type of
play that black is hoping for uh to get
something going but he didn't play e4 he
did take the rook on b1 although as you
say there was a hesitation
no no he did play e4 oh i'm sorry he did
play e4 oops
i
i thought we saw rook takes people on i
apologize i mean after you mentioned e5
e4 it was also obvious that it should be
on the board not pretty soon
i thought sometimes i get confused i'm
looking at the analysis board and mostly
it's the analysis board and then i kind
of look over there to the light board
the light board being the smaller board
on the right
uh i get a little bit thrown off but
okay peter and we didn't see the move
rook v6
rather we saw hikaru playing rook b3
yeah obviously of course it's a very
natural move because you keep an eye on
this bishop uh basically this stops
black from taking on fc since it's
hanging the bishop cannot move because
then the pawn on e4 will be hanging and
the this explains why of course magnus
brings his knight into the game because
this knight on f8 was
really far from the action knight g6
also making sure that there are no more
forks on e7 maybe the knight somewhere
can uh join the action on the king side
slippering also some look eight
i mean the position is
is sharp
[Music]
the thing is you know i have this this
bar and i see that this bar indicates
that white is clearly better or supposed
to be clearly better if i would not be
seeing this bar i wouldn't be okay i
would say that yeah why it is better but
i'm not buying this what the computer is
saying that this is so obvious
right
for all of those in our audience you see
this white bar
on the live screenshot kind of giving an
indication
the higher it goes up the greater
advantage for white when you see almost
no
white bar whatsoever that means that
black
position is for choice and black is
winning
and uh i'm with you peter i mean
unfortunately that bar
is so prejudicial to our outlooks it you
know it tempers everything we're gonna
say
but really without the bar i just seen
the move knight e5 i see two bishops
i see a majority on the king side for
black and okay yeah i i like the rook
don't get me wrong i like the rook when
it was on b6 too by the way uh but here
i i
wouldn't say the game's over whereas the
bar indicates to me that there's a very
big advantage for white maybe too big in
in a practical game between two human
beings peter
yeah but i mean uh if it would be
humanly plus two or something that would
be really bad news for black but
humanities doesn't feel like uh plus two
not even maybe plus one but that's
already even a little bit maybe an
overstatement hikaru goes for the b8
that's a move that if it works then
practically that's the move you want to
make because it clarifies things on the
other hand now look at this bar doesn't
know what to think about this move
but that's the human move because we've
all been taught
uh for
from from the time i started learning
chess in fact you know went ahead
material just trade down you know just
trade
pieces trade down and drag your opponent
to
the doom and when you see the knight on
v8 you're actually thinking oh this is
terrific because i get to take the a6
pawn and then i'll just win by queening
the a pawn but it has
that this exchange has cost
uh
ikaru is h2 pawn is that significant
peter
i mean it cost him this pawn on the
other hand by the speed he is uh
blissing out his music its kind of
signals us that he knows what he's doing
but it it might be also an impression he
wants to
impose on his opponent like you know you
are done on time you are on one minute
and i'm very confident and uh
i believe that this strategy usually
works very well against many people on
the other hand i'm not sure if if it's
the right strategy against magnus
because it doesn't matter how long time
magnus goes if he believes that he gets
a chance then he he will use it so time
will not not be a factor of course it's
very unpleasant for him if time and the
position together that elites then even
magnus carson cannot do anything against
it now he played the move bishop e5 he
is still fighting he's kicking well no
question about it and i love this move
bishop e5 because black had the choice
of going h3h2 and trying to get a queen
on h1
but after h3 knight a6 h2
white will be very happy to give up his
bishop he will play bishop takes h2
give up his bishop or maybe even as you
say but i was thinking he was going to
give up his bishop and go knight c7
so from black's point of view black was
thinking that okay if he could trade off
the dark square bishops
um
the h pawn becomes even more of a
potent
force so that i love that little bishop
e5 by magnus in the game position i mean
and
after
uh
i don't know i mean
it feels to me like three results i
don't know if that's an exaggeration but
it
it feels sharp like that like the
position is by no means cut and dry
yeah absolutely i mean nobody knows what
is going on now so hikaru is slowly
catching up magnus in time and one thing
we should also mention from practical
point of view the player who is already
done on time gets used to this situation
while the other player who is having the
comfortable situation of having more
time on the clock is
all of a sudden confronted with
position is getting out of control and
i'm getting out or getting long time
this is a very dangerous scenario many
many people have lost their games
because of this okay i think if one guy
can handle this situation perfectly well
then it's it's hikaru
because he's of course
insanely good in all these double edge
situations but
this one is not really really tricky and
so much so he just played the move
c5 peter and knight takes a6 going into
an ending where the a pawn was rushing
that was awfully awfully tempting but
it's kind of slow at the same time as
well in a weird way right
so he decided
that he was going to go
whole hog with
c5 and try to push his deep on up the
board
yeah i mean that's
that's what he relies on on the other
hand
i believe as as a black player you feel
like
if
if you already got here because it
looked
much more unpleasant before you are kind
of happy the only question magnus is 10
to 30 seconds on the clock
does he have the time to really assess
this position i mean it's such a wild
complicated stuff that definitely would
love to have extra one two minutes to to
orient it but he doesn't have this
luxury so he has to go with his
instincts and he has taken
with dtx e5 d6 hc on the board i mean
it's an incredible fight
uh truly uh
the desirable d7 however i mean if i'm
in black shoes i mean i feel like i just
landed on my feet i've got this
beautiful bishop on e4 which controls h1
which is the coronation square for my
bishop i feel like man i've got real
chances
in this game and whoa he didn't
yeah exactly and you know after d7
magnus even had the composure to to play
knight f7 because
i think it was very natural just to take
on d7 play h2 and you feel like you you
cannot lose this game anymore
right
and he goes knight f7 already smelling
blood or what
exactly because how we how are we
stopping h2
h1 winning an entire rook yeah that was
actually no way and we are having now
the position after knight a6 h2 knight
xc5 h1 queen
luke takes h1 bishop h1 on the board
magnus is about to make a comeback or is
this a phone together with the d phone
enough to to guarantee white safety
after all okay so let's imagine knight
e6
but then we
can our knight get trapped like a
bishop d5 i don't know uh
what we have 96 on the book
on the board i wanted to say it's kind
of like a tatsuji that's a a
term that i get from the japanese game
of go
where you go bishop d5 queen and at the
end of the day the bishop dominates the
knight and that's
the term to suji where the the but in
this case i can't keep it because there
is king
king d4 maybe this is winning now
suddenly for magnus
right this this position
should be winning because the pawn end
game right at the end white's one move
too
too slow
uh so right peter i was almost
going to suggest g5 king d4
f4 king d5 f3
as some crazy uh variation
because if you can't take the bishop
then the knight
is perpetually stuck
yeah okay it was a ultra sharp
possibility i i don't know what what
play king f8 instead
oh well that's a winning king and pawn
end game because he's in the box
so
yeah
i think
he got the chance to play a6
and after king e7 he managed to go
knight b7
[Music]
okay
and g5 played
holy smokes uh
[Music]
my first impression is that it's winning
for black
i mean the the computer doesn't seem to
be impressed by the way
john we had this most amazing game uh it
was a super duper sharp end game between
ding lyrin
and magnus and the and the super
computer cc
said it was no problem it was a draw
throughout for magnus and we were
thinking that ding
had all of these marvelous winning
opportunities of uh
different my minor pieces look at this
what happened
yeah well there was simply a very forced
sequence how
white was able to save the game with
knight d8 check king d6 and a7 and there
is an escape thanks to this phone on a7
knight f7 check is coming so you cannot
you cannot keep your material and magnus
kind of
agreed that okay draw is a draw
wow
my goodness i i feel like i was just on
a roller coaster ride peter with all
kinds of ups and downs a lot of twists
and turns in this one
i'm a little bit uh taken aback i don't
know what to say your take on this
remarkable game
yeah well i mean
at the end it was very very dramatic and
i think magnus can be really
happy that he gets another chance to
play with the white pieces because if he
would have
lost this game and around
right at the middle it looked very
unpleasant for him he had no time and he
was facing the situation if he loses
then he loses two-day set but he escaped
he managed to get counter play but
we have tanya here and i think she has
something to share
thanks peter indeed magnus did survive
that which means that we got another
game in this uh
first set of the final uh magnus carlsen
has to win to take it to the tie break
so which would mean two games of blitz
so we've still got some time and i just
wanted to jump in and have a quick chat
with john john hi it's so good to see
you here
anya how are you doing
i'm doing very well did you enjoy that
game
yeah no this was this was quite
interesting it was uh extremely
complicated early on and then it felt
like hikaru had
i don't know what felt like a very sort
of stable position you can sit on and
then
we got this really complicated end game
that just looks fascinating that i still
don't quite follow everything but a
really enjoyable game to be able to be
on and sort of
listen to peter and yasser and their
sort of commentary so thank you for
having me
it's exactly the kind of end game that
you actually want to sit down set up the
chess board and go through move by move
because it's so complex
john i remember that
when i met you at actually before that i
want to ask you are you are you team
hikaru for this final
well that's a great question i'm uh i'm
generally sort of unbiased although i
have to say that uh
yeah i'm generally unbiased
that's that's too politically correct to
be accepted on this show exactly
okay if i if i have to pick i have to
say that i
i associate slightly more with magnus's
sort of uh style of play i would say
oh all right i'm ashamed of you i i i'm
i'm all about objectivity and neutrality
just as you are
and i'm i'm thinking the americans gonna
win
[Music]
you know john i remember meeting you in
st louis um and i think one of the most
uh fascinating things for me was
when you know you've
you've done a master's in math you've
been a professional football player
you've written a book uh mine and mata
you've um you've done a phd from mit
just such varied achievements and for me
that was
that was just really interesting and i'm
just wondering if chess
you know as being this ultimate brain
game and and a spot which kind of feels
like it's combining your sporting career
as well as your interest in academia is
that something is that what drew you to
chess uh do you think chess is like a
midpoint balancing your mind out
well i think that's perfectly reasonable
i think that sort of chess
is a great example of a game where you
sort of combine sort of
very
deep quantitative reasoning with this
sort of competitive spirit but uh sadly
i have to say that uh i really enjoy
chess
from more of a sort of aesthetic
perspective sort of analyzing chess
positions things like this and
somehow what draws me to chess is just
the sort of beauty of the game
rather than let's say the
the thrill of competition or the thrill
of winning
i would say for me personally at least
which may come as a surprise
i am surprised because you are a
professional football player tell me one
thing which as if you had to translate
certain ways of thinking that chess has
impacted you on
uh to professional football and towards
your interest in
in math and in academia in general how
would you translate the approach that
perhaps you've picked up from chess
so it's uh it's sort of funny because i
i really came to chess late in my life
i didn't really start playing chess sort
of regularly and sort of learning how to
sort of think about chess until
i was late in college and at that point
i was sort of already fully formed as a
football player and as a mathematician
but i would say that somehow my
experiences with math have really shaped
sort of my experiences in chess i would
say you know early on the thing that
first drew me to chess was uh
trying to analyze sort of simple end
games and come to a definite conclusion
about a position something that's sort
of
very much a mathematical type pursuit
and i would say that one thing that
chess has sort of given me is that over
time i've come to really
appreciate sort of uncertainty in trying
to sort of
make sense of you know things that are
quite complicated and quite uh
sort of non-intuitive i mean chess is
you know it's such a
simple game in many ways you know
there's not too many pieces
there's the rules aren't too complicated
but somehow you get this great
complexity out of it which is you know
quite beautiful
it's very beautiful but when you say
chess is a simple game john i i
my mind doesn't take that in because i i
mean you know you see these guys play
and you're just you just feel like you
don't it's so difficult to understand as
well tell me one thing you know you've
you've been a part of the chess um
fraternity in some ways uh especially in
st louis you met you met all these top
players and being a professional sports
person yourself uh being an athlete
yourself
who do you
who do you admire the most in terms of
uh how they are as an athlete uh you
know the skills that they have
over the board but also off the board
oh this is uh this is a tough one i have
to say uh
so someone who i had the chance to meet
who i i really admire and respect is uh
sam shankland i would say is actually a
name that comes to mind and the reason
why i say sam is just getting the chance
to meet him and sort of interact with
him
this is a person who is an extremely
extremely hard worker he loves chess
and this person works on chess sort of
non-stop and i have to say that from
interacting with you know different
let's say professional athletes
you sort of you come to meet the
professional athletes who have this
amazing talent who have this like these
god-given gifts and are just you know
can do these amazing things
but somehow i've always come to
appreciate the people who who yes have
some talent but
are truly the hardest working people on
the team and somehow this is
you know the type of person that i have
a lot of respect for
i couldn't agree more with you john i i
know sam a little bit and i think he is
the example of how hard work and how
hard work is actually a lot more
important than talent and it can take
you way further than talent tell me one
thing john like in your professional
career as a footballer do you feel that
um
the achievements that you had
do you feel that you had an innate
talent or do you think it was hard work
that helped you be where you were
oh i think it was uh it was a lot of
hard work i mean i was uh i think i was
a fairly talented athlete but not
anything special and i would say
sort of a real commitment and sort of
desire to sort of
actually be a top college football was
sort of my dream from when i was a
little kid be a top college football
player this is what really sort of
drove me to sort of
do better than sort of other players who
i felt had much more talent than me
all right right now john um i know that
you you have to leave us soon but i have
to um
i have to ask you one last question
before i let you go and you know this
this entire event especially the finals
and also the magnus carlson chess store
has been all really about uh everything
that chess has given back to the
community and now drawing a full circle
by giving back to the community through
chess tell us
one of your impact chess stories uh tell
us something a moment that you remember
with chess that has left
that has left a big impact on you
yeah no i actually i have a i have a
pretty good story so i uh you know i'm
very much an amateur chess player i i
spend most of my time on math and other
things but uh
when i do study chess one of my favorite
players is a guy by the name of
anderson
and uh i
one of my friends anna rudolph you know
very very nice international master
she actually knew alf and mentioned me
to him and uh
he actually out of the kindness of his
heart invited me to come visit him and
stay with him for a few days and sort of
analyze chess and spend time with him
and i have to say that
ulf is truly one of the kindest people
i've ever met in my life and just
to see someone who loves chess so much
that you know he he hears about some
stranger who you know appreciated his
games and he just
invites me to come visit him picks me up
at the airport uh you know it's uh
it was a really heartwarming experience
for me i have to say that this is the
nicest person i've ever met in sort of
any area of my life and you know he was
a professional chess player
ah that's really incredible john and i i
think i'm totally with peter when he
said you know in the middle of the of
the game that just it was so amazing to
see you so into the game and just
enjoying and soaking up all the action
thank you so much on for joining us
today it's been an absolute pleasure
absolutely thanks for having me
thank you john i just wanted to say that
i old anderson was my second in the
candidates in montpelier in 1985 and i
couldn't agree with you more that off is
just
just a sweetheart
[Music]
thank you
all right let's take a look at the score
now we've got one more game coming up
and magnus carlsen in a win on demand
situation if he has to take the match
forward i think that was
a big save from magnus hikaru nakamura i
have to say has been looking like the
one who is
i'm not going to use the word dominating
but been on top throughout the three
games that we have seen he's been the
one who's been pushing from the word go
managed to get that big win in game two
and if we can just quickly bring up uh
bring up that game because i think it
was it was really interesting to see how
things developed and just give me a
moment
yes and yeah uh yes you were asking me
that where is it that things perhaps
went wrong for white for magnus carlsen
yeah i think he paid really well he uh
he fought for the initiative and he got
that and if you just move a little
forward i think all of this was was just
incredibly played he creates his
initiative and right about here
he made the move king f2 him and it's
not it's not a mistake the game still
goes on and there's still balance but
there was a really pretty idea that the
computer shows and it's it's maybe hard
to find over the board but i think it's
it shows us how an initiative can be
developed d5 is interesting but take a
look at this move so what black if we
just back out what black wants to do is
play queen b7 push but push back all of
black white's pieces and sort of
stabilize his own position so the move
rook f4 is is a suggestion which i
really like it's not even the computer
stop move but i really liked this idea
and the whole point is that now white
has a threat of going knight to g5
just building up on this attack and on
this initiative and trying to put
pressure on the f7 pawn a move like
queen b7 because what you want to do is
drive out that white queen from the
seventh rank is still met by knight g5
wow
and just taking advantage of the fact
that queen queen c7 you've got 96 knight
c7 that's a that's a end game that
you're probably not even playing for two
results white's got a big advantage over
there and if instead of queen c7 the
computer recommends a line like king g8
why check this out yes white continues
to put pressure along the f7 with bishop
h5 and just how the initiative develops
i think and like i said this is not this
is not the first line that the computer
computer gives in but this is just a
really
nice way of how the of how the attack
could have been developed but instead
what magnus did with king f2
unfortunately what happened with that
was that his pieces started falling back
uh move by move and even though the
computer gives this as an even position
it's not exactly equality you know even
though it shows 0.0 or just about around
that some of the engines it's it's
really a crazy it's a hot mess on the
board and anything can happen and then
if we move on a little further peter
just a very important moment in the game
after magnus traded off the queens
and right about here bishop e2 was
played here
and bishop a3 and here the computer has
a really nice idea of how white can
regroup white needs to get out of this
mess around the king and the bishop and
sort of just regroup his pieces g4 was a
move that is being criticized by the
engines which gives which transfers the
edge to black but check out this
construction
that i had to look at in which white
just has a plan to go 91 and we can just
have arrows on the board because moves
don't matter here knight e1 knight goes
to d3 your king goes to f3 and the
knight transfers to e4 wire f2 and then
you're jumping to f6 and d6 and it's
it's it's a position that's really white
cannot be worse here
unfortunately after g4 hikaru nakamura
was just on fire and converted the
position in a flawless manner amazing
technique shown that by the american and
game three a survivor really by magnus
carlsen and on that note we're off to
we're off to game four magnus carlsen
must win situation yes peter
let's go
thank you tanya and a big thank you to
both of our guests for joining us and
sharing their experiences
um
peter uh magnus by choosing the english
shows that he wasn't so happy about the
outcome of
game two even though i thought he had an
advantage in game two he is the first to
switch as we say he blinked first
yeah i think there is a good argument
for this good reason for this the point
is that
i'm pretty sure we would have never seen
uh the repeat of the
of this vienna variation from hikaru but
the point that hikaru can play the ultra
solid queen's gambit was probably not
something uh magnus wanted to face in
this must-win situation so he felt like
this is much more
i mean c4 and since hikaru meets c4 with
e5
maybe can lead to more complex fights
and not as solid as as the other one
i mean the point is like also tanya very
nicely showed this second game i mean
this second game should really hurt
magnus big time because he might have
felt like he should have won that game
and if he would have won that game he
would have been in a very comfortable
situation i also felt like the third
game little bit uh was played out of
frustration from magnus also the way he
played he was burning a lot of time and
everything like if he haven't really
digested yet uh what has happened to him
in this in this second game i also do
remember what he called was always
telling and tanya was interviewing him
uh during all this lindo de sabe and
also in earlier events that uh hikar was
saying that whoever wins the first game
and especially if he does it with the
black pieces it puts such a big pressure
on your opponent psychologically also
and also chess wise that it's very
difficult to handle so in this sense
this huge victory for hikaru in game two
almost won the match right away because
he was very very close to to win the
game three but magnus gets another
chance and we are in for some very
complex video game which i
don't really have much of an experience
maybe i should hand it over to you
because you are the you are the
english expert
right okay so
this line with e2 e3 traditionally
hasn't really been met with d5 i think a
lot of black players prefer to play
bishop b4
and
not to allow d5 cb5 knight d5
bishop b5 i beg your pardon
because they're fearful that in this set
of circumstance you have to play the
move knight take c3
and after b takes e3 well white's b2
pawn now has
playing a role in the center and after
bishop d bishop b6 d4
uh
i think a lot of players in the olden
days kind of just stopped and said
uh
you know like well i'm helping white
build up uh too big a center now having
said that today
uh again the the chess engines you know
have kind of rewritten i want to say our
opening books peter i mean that we all
used to sing
from the encyclopedia of chess openings
the the hymn book
there
and today the chess engines have
basically said well in a lot of
positions that we thought were
maybe unplayable there's a lot of
resources and this might just be an
example of uh hikaru kind of drilling
down with his engine and saying hey
what's my problem i i've developed my
king's safe
yeah you've got a big pawn on c3 that
might have been on b2 and a little bit
more center to control but there's
absolutely nothing wrong with black's
position
and i would agree i i i like the the
extra center pawn but maybe
you know
players of my generation
over
emphasized
central control and the engines today
say
it's it's it's not that big a deal so
at the moment for a must-win game there
is imbalances but maybe my magnus isn't
all that happy either
yeah i couldn't agree more it just uh
i think also the the strategy of hikaru
you know because it seems like all the
time he comes up with something which
magnus
was not really expecting yeah he wants
to take magnus out of his comfort zone
uh force him to burn time right from the
beginning and so far this strategy has
worked perfectly for hikaru in today's
match right of course
the big question is
how many such ideas you can create and
he had the advantage of having two extra
days my magnus only one
and it seems to me you remember we were
discussing it also on the show with
hikaru that he was saying that yeah
everywhere magnus is a little bit better
and to me it seems like he wants to
deliberately take all the games to such
uh circumstances where this little bit
difference does not play any at all he
wants to bring it to his own territory
and he forces magnus into time trouble
and all these resources all these
complex positions where hikaru excels so
far it's it worked perfectly now let's
see if magnus can fight back
well exactly i think that that's a very
good way of of of describing what
hikaru's strategy has got to be when
hikaru looks at
even the scales and says okay i'm better
here or better there or
magnus keeps being bit but better what
do i have to do to upset my opponent
well one thing is i've got to surprise
them i've got to come with a lot of new
ideas that forces my opponent to burn
time on the clock
when he is
thinking
uh a lot
then
that will be where my opportunity
is
to to to grab a victory so by mixing his
openings and
uh preparing you know little new ideas
here and there you can really really
benefit i was about to say
before the move bishop takes c6 was
played
i had expected uh white
to play the new bishop d3
and i had a funny idea in mind peter uh
the idea was to take on d4
take with the e pawn
and in case of rookie eight check i
really want i like this idea a lot like
bishop e3
and in case of bishop f4 i wanted to
castle
and you know get a discovered attack
against the queen
but magnus's decision to take on c6
i don't think that this was his first
choice and he already you know he's
feeling uncomfortable he's he you know
the openings
you got to give hikaru's team a great
deal of credit uh almost in all the
games it seems to me that hikaru is the
one who is actually
has more time on the clock
and uh that's tough
you know magnus is really really well
prepared i mean this
this is a world champion who works hard
on his game it's not easy
uh to
to to find a place where he doesn't have
some awareness
and
well uh so far
the strategy has worked great
great for ikaro
uh peter i'm not really
that impressed by
this capture
of opposite colored bishops
maybe magnus thinks that he's going to
take twice on e5 and somehow get in f3
e4 and have a better middle game
position
uh
for a must win game
uh i think black is happy with the
outcome
exactly i mean i also have the feeling
that uh
the point by playing bishop takes c6 and
short castle white is sooner or later
and probably sooner than later forced to
exchange on e5 because i mean you don't
want to give black the chance of playing
e5 e4 because black might just win the
game after let's say some knight d2
queen g6 bishop h3 coming all the black
species eyeing white's king and without
the light squad bishop
this this possession can be very very
dangerous so after rookie 8 basically it
feels almost
obligatory for white to take on e5 or
first to play e4 this is i think the the
question which uh magnus is thinking
about can he first play e4 because if he
could play e4 then of course he would
like to play e4 and then to capture on
e5 and get this structure as he as yasir
mentioned with with fc with the pawns fc
e4 in the opposite colored bishop
position but even if white might be
hoping for some symbolic advantage
because black can always break that
structure with some timely f7 f5 one has
the feeling that uh this is not the
dream scenario for a mastering game
not only that peter but there is a
tricky yeah that was about to say in the
position that you had after e4
there is a a tricky take on d4 in what
you were mentioning cd
queen g6 and this bishop coming to h3
you know it's a little bit off-putting i
don't like this pen i don't like bishop
h3 coming and so magnus i think would
have preferred to play e4 i think that
this is the reason he didn't instead he
took twice
on e5 and i'm sure he's about to prepare
f3 and e4
as well
yeah and we have this on the board yeah
this is the this is the situation why it
wants to go fce4
that's why i mentioned the move e4 that
if it's possible it would be great but
yeah of course it
gave black way too many options so
i mean if this would be game one
i would say that okay it's a perfectly
sensible opening choice or not choice
because it was not magnus's choice he
was forced into this position but that
magnus can be quite happy with this
because okay no risk maybe chances of
some very little pressure on the other
hand in a must win game when the
opponent is ahead on the clock
and has a very easy game i mean i don't
know exactly what is the right way but
something like bishop a6 followed by
rook ada trying to land something on
this is also very natural followed by
some c5 c4 i mean there are all these
options or also the move that hikaru
chose the move f7 f5 stopping any kind
of e3 force and now you have to deal
with this weakness on e3 and also the
phonon is slightly weak with with black
powerful queen on e5
exactly i i f7 f5 uh
good move don't get me wrong i i
i'm all for it uh another move instead
of the move f5 is i kind of like what
you suggested peter which was let white
play the move e4 then hit him with f5 so
a move like rook v8 just just just
a move right and imagining e3 e4 as a
potential response f7 f5
you don't really want to capture on f5
you just bring out the bishop with tempo
and black's rooks are actually on the
open files in the position and you know
white's gonna have to play catch up in
terms of development um
not bad i i think that uh
black is more than satisfied with the
outcome he did play f5 not and that's a
perfectly
decent move as well and like you say
bishop a6 and rook d8 could be on his
agenda in the meanwhile this light this
pardon me this um dark square bishop
this bishop on c1 is kind of like you
know
he's not earning his keep we gotta we
gotta put that guy
guy to work and the way to do that i
think is to play rookie one and e4
yeah i mean the big question is
how to activate this bishop because
i mean tonight now it looks like black
has everything on the console why
doesn't really have chances but this can
easily change i mean let's just imagine
that this bishop somehow gets powerful
on the on the long diagonal right in
order to get powerful actually it would
be even nice to just remove this pawn
from c3 get a chance especially after
rookie one night that fight protected
the easter pawn get bishop to with the
temple go queen f2 later try to go queen
g3 and then we already see that after
black has committed a move like f7 f5
the long diagonal is forever damaged
black never has the chance of playing f7
f6 closing down the long diagonal i
think this is the
only kind of idea
whether with bishop b2 or later with
easy and then bishop is the bishop d4
but somehow black has white has to try
to use this long diagonal and pressure
on the g7 pawn
fantastico i couldn't agree with you
more that's exactly the strategies of
both players aware i do think that black
should
should not delay
and should be i want to say uh forcing
uh the action whatever it is uh don't
let white just play a lot of
safety moves with b1 c4 bishop d2 but
really really get it going uh just a
quick uh commercial time out a bit here
i want to say welcome each and every one
of you thank you so much for joining us
for this magnus carlson uh
tour final
benefiting kiva we are we are doing a
fundraising uh where by joining chess 24
and becoming a premium member half of
your membership goes to support the kiva
organization earlier in the day we had
an interview with henrique
who explained
all about what kiva does and i think it
was a very inspiring
conversation
so you could do that also i just wanted
to say that yesterday chessable released
a very special course the magnus
carlson endgame light touch course you
could download an entire lesson for free
by going to chessbull.com
so be sure to do that and finally
another way you can just support is this
just tell your friends where you're
hanging out uh we are in the first
set
of what promises to be a very exciting
seven set final the winner of course
is the first to win four
sets
uh we don't expect anybody to be wiped
out in fact we expect a very very close
match that this is where we're going to
be hanging out before we hope a week and
so let all your friends know and to join
us with the chat
um
that was the commercial time out getting
back to the game peter rook b8 uh on the
board uh where do we see magnus by the
way sorry i should just say once again
magnus trails in the first set two to
one he's got to win this game with the
white pieces to force a pair of blitz
games uh peter what is magnus got to do
yeah that's that's the big question
because higa played the move that you
had also suggested this little little
move rook b8 it looks like it doesn't
really do much but in fact it does first
of all it stops exactly the idea the
plan that white would love to do with
rook b1 playing cc c4 and get the bishop
to the long diagonal after duke vietnam
if white plays the move look b1 then
unfortunately the opponent sees the
gonna fall
and it's not just the pawn but white is
also missing the coordination to create
real compensation
so
but if you are not able to play rook b1
then how you gonna untangle you cannot
play cc4 because the rook on a1 is
hanging
you don't really want to develop the
bishop to d2
maybe finally white will have to do this
but the problem is that
after bishop d2 cc c4 is never really a
threat because then black will hit you
with luke b2
and
there is no good way of reacting to it
having said that magnus had finally
played the move bishop d2 after
something like almost four minutes of
hesitation simply because of
the fact that there was nothing else
well i mean you know you say four
minutes of hesitation i said wait a
minute you got 15 minutes for the entire
game spending four minutes i understand
spending's four minutes when you want to
launch a combination
uh a deep peace sacrifice
and stirring up a lot of trouble uh
bishop d2 is not number one you know the
greatest confidence building move i've
ever seen
and number two to spend that much time
uh is not a good sign for magnus carlson
fans
yeah not at all i mean simply also the
pressure is too high yeah he's in a must
win situation and that's exactly the
reason why move like bishop d2 feels too
slow you you feel like you want to be
much more energetic you would like to
get the initiative but i mean
there is no initiative yet you have to
get your pieces out and only once you
get them out if you get them out you can
do more think about initiative
so yeah it's
i'm pretty sure that if magnus would be
given a chance to to sacrifice something
then he would do it almost instantly
but here uh with this confronted with
the situation that the position doesn't
really suit this uh must win situation
game
this is this is also tough
psychologically he needs to digest but
he also doesn't have time to digest this
situation and so he has to cook what he
i mean with what he can and bishop d2
was the best start in this direction
right now from from black's perspectives
too i think that's a really good way of
uh putting it you know you got to get
the pieces out you know i mean we all
want to sacrifice our pieces i i want to
sacrifice my opponent's pieces more than
i want to sacrifice mine but we all want
to sacrifice our pieces and then go on
the attack and checkmate and and so
forth and so on but you got to get the
pieces out and so i was just
leading up to the idea that isn't it
time for bishop e6 and get the pieces
out peter
yeah bishop e6 absolutely i mean uh
imagine if the black bishop lands on c4
i mean
then all these dynamic ideas with ccc4
will never work so it's now or never
that white tries to break out and yeah
magnus uses this moment to go easy for
the only question is
that yeah it will allow many exchanges
and uh yeah you open up the e-file well
black is so active he has all these
intel media checks and something uh
later challenging the rook on e4 if
black captures on e4
which is by far not not necessary yet
right but looking again this was kind of
one of those models where i was saying
like if i'm in a car issues i'm trying
to make well not trying to make a draw i
would desire to make the draw my
opponent wants to lose that's his
problem uh take on e4 rook takes e4
bishop f5 you were saying it could lead
to a massive simplification
simplification
sometimes when you're playing for a draw
though peter you can overdo it
you can
give your opponent chances
by being too direct
exactly i mean perfectly right
yeah it always seems like yeah with more
and more changes we are getting closer
to it though but i mean if white somehow
managed to get his bishop to d4
and keep the rooks or at least one pair
of looks then and we'll be able to start
torturing black then actually thanks to
the better pawn structure there are real
practical chances to succeed so of
course if black has everything under
control and can make sure that actually
you have no time to activate your bishop
and i gonna enter with my look and for
some uh
direct segments of moves then you can do
it but you have to be very careful
exactly just continuing this
plan if you will peter because it's just
so very very consequent it is very very
forcing
in this sequence if yeah you you more or
less
need to keep
a rook i didn't know if you wanted to
take on e
8 or not okay in this system i wanted to
keep the e file
okay
uh we'll trade rooks
rook takes rook takes
rook b2
and you know trying to get
our uh
um
play uh on the uh
with the apon and
i'll get it out in a moment aha rook to
e7 so your dream of course is to bring
your bishop to d4 or anywhere on that
diagonal to take the g pawn right
and uh if i take your a-bond you're
probably not even worried about the c7
bond but just
positioning your bishop
and this is where i'm saying you know
something can potentially go wrong
when you you're playing so hard to make
a draw you're desperate to make a draw
you trade but you're giving your
opponent as you're pointing out
uh a chance here yeah yeah there was one
moment you know what i was really a
little bit afraid of after rook takes
e4 bishop f5 takes takes look a1 if you
play the little move king f7
keeping the status co because how i
gonna keep this keep this e file
right
looks like a d um well
but here don't are you a lot yes exactly
are you allowing to move rook a5 peter
and then
i think you're absolutely right you've
got to keep
you know at least one rope your
preference would be for both but at
least one and here at least the rook on
a5 is doing damage right
yeah absolutely yeah i mean this is also
very dangerous because finally if you
start to take care of your pawn then i
will have time to activate my bishop
start expanding on the king side and
this is exactly what magnus is dreaming
about
never give him such chance but hikaru
did play the move ftx e4 and we are
seeing this line
yeah and again it's such a forcing line
um i'm not surprised but also
uh bishop d2
uh well maybe it's not the way you
really want to play for win uh but it is
better i mean that there's the double
pawns
on c6 and c7 which means they're not
going to be a candidate
for passer and white does have a a nice
majority on the
on the
king side peter maybe it's just not
enough but it's white for choice
wow magnus played the move queen beastly
check
what
yes after bishop f5 i mean it's a very
nice
very nice move but i'm not sure if
if he gets what he wants because hikaru
anticipated it and instead of taking it
this would have been magnus's idea that
this case he gets this opposite
bishop and game with with even better
structure
but hikaru side stepped it with the move
queen d5
okay
luke xd8 rook takes e8 and bishop f4 on
the board
okay since rook e2 was the big threat
uh
moving the bishop away in advance makes
perfect logical sense
um
i don't know i mean it feels to me like
white has a long-term plus
yeah that has a long-term plus but i
feel like with the e-file open
i have i have a lot of dynamics and
now contrary to the other line uh in
fact black look black's look might be
very very
active in in all those end games when
white collects the phones i'm not really
liking i'm not a fan of collecting the
pawn and magnus is also not going along
that line after bishop e6 he said okay
we have been already
for too long discussing if we will get
an end game or not let me keep the
queens with queen a3
[Music]
okay
because let's just imagine the scenario
if white captures because all it almost
looks like a free pawn but then black
gets the chance of activating the look
to e2 and hitting the e2 pawn and after
a4 i can even play a move like okay to
forcing the exchange of looks or at
least try to force because definitely
you're gonna try rookie one you have to
try right but this is not not the
scenario magnus even wanted to think
about
so he decided to sidestep and keep the
queens
queen a3 makes a
perfect sense
now in this position with the pawn on f3
i always like you know i i've seen too
many checkmating patterns where queen
ends up on e1 it was like no no no no
you just have to be careful that there's
no
issues with the king and if there are no
issues with the king there's a lot of
targets in black's position uh peter
yeah if y gets active then uh long terms
simply because of the fact that he has
this fc g2 pawn structure
uh
compared to black's g7 h7 so
while he's protecting his weakness on g2
with a very powerful pawn on fc closing
the long diagonal if ever white gets the
chance of
being active on the long diagonal then
there is no way to defend the g7 pawn
only with the with the piece and that
would mean that you are on the defensive
so this is what uh magnus has to try to
make use of hikaru did play the move a6
a6
whoa uh always when i'm looking at
magnus's uh expression on camera
it's really hard for me to discern
when he's worried or when he's happy
like right now i think he should be
happy and yet he's wearing a look of
quiet concern so it's very hard for me
to
read
magnus are you any better peter
uh you've played against magnus or yeah
is is it easy for you to read him and
know when he's worried or when he's
happy
yeah i have played a lot with him but i
can't really say that i i could read him
uh i think however here the situation
why he's not concerned because he feels
that he has a chance
and he wants to make the most out of his
chance while often then we see that he
he doesn't show any sign of emotions it
simply means to him that okay nothing
really is happening in the position now
he's in a must-win situation he feels
like he after all somehow improved his
possession he he managed to get
strategically at least what he was kind
of hoping for to get because he couldn't
really hope for more on the other hand
uh with the black queen on d5 and the
black hook on e8
uh black is quite active i mean let's
just imagine if black moves the bishop
back to f7 gets pawn to h6 just to make
sure that his king is totally safe and
is ready to enter with the rook
it might mean that the white has to deal
with a lot of activity from the black
side of course one can argue that okay
if i am writing all these scenarios why
can any moment go do one yes you can but
after looking on bishop f7 you are kind
of uh not really wanting to exchange a
pair of rooks and this is exactly the
problem but
you have to fight for the e-file and
magnus did chose after some hesitation
some almost two minutes the movie won
okay um
[Music]
because there's a lot of people in our
audience uh theater uh they're asking
themselves
why not capture the pawn on a6 what was
it that magnus
didn't like about munching that pawn
well if you take on a6 then you give
away the c5 square you lose the control
of the dark squares and black gets this
very very nasty check on c5 and after
king h1 he has another nasty follow up
with bishop c4 and all of a sudden your
queen is in trouble black is very active
even don't want to look any further it
just feels completely wrong
and
magnus's play is very logical i mean i
think this is how you want to play the
the position
only the tournament situation the match
situation is the the question so manus
traded the rooks
and played the movie hd just as for
black h6 is very useful to have a king
shelter on h7 but also wants to make
sure that he can place the king on h2
try to because thanks to the queens on
the board he can still combine play
against g7 pawn and the weaknesses on
the queen side why still has uh i mean
white has an age the question is can he
really
play for a win here
well uh
asked and i would answer yes why not uh
michael bodminick amongst many other
great world champions uh taught us
that bishops of opposite color middle
games and it's hard you can't really
call this a middle game it feels more
like an ending
with only queens and bishops the bishops
of opposite color
middle games it's all about
king safety
and the player
who has the initiative against the
opponent's king
usually has a
big maybe even in some cases decisive
advantage and the reason is because uh
the the player with the initiative is
going to play on the squares that he has
the bishop and you can't counter attack
okay counter that in other words in this
position
uh
uh magnus has the dark square bishop and
therefore he wants to play on the dark
squares as you can see he's going to put
his bishop on
e5 and as peter you've been mentioning
attacked upon on g7 conversely
uh g2 h3 f3 doesn't mean that once you
put the bishop on d5
you're going to be
counter-attacking on the light squares
so i see this
in my view as a nearly decisive position
for magnus
nearly decisive just because
i i want to see how he's going to
attack g7
but i i think it's a big advantage
yeah it is a big advantage simply it's a
free pawn and
as we already you explained i explained
yeah thanks to the structure with fcg2
you have all this shelter you put the
bishop on e5
but of course since all the looks all
the heavy pieces have been exchanged a
part of the queens it's not so easy to
get this attack going
uh on the other hand one can argue that
okay why do you need this attack so
desperately uh simply the point is that
opposite colored bishop end games are
always drawn so in order to make
progress you really have to
somehow target black's king and whenever
finally you put bishop on e5 and black
makes sure that he is able to protect
this g7 pawn then you will have to and
queen e6 played you will have to somehow
start moving your pawns
and if you start moving your pawns then
black will have all kinds of perpetual
check ideas i mean let's just imagine
the scenario white goes some king h2 g4
with the bishop on e5 then if black
manages to enter somehow then it will be
very awkward for the white king
this is the this is the practical
problem
what will happen in a game and
especially in almost like a blitz game
because this is already not not even a
rapid game they are both down to almost
two and a half minutes he can do less
than four minutes on the clock but with
the ten seconds increment one can say
that time will not be a decisive factor
in this game
much more if white will be able to find
the right way or to pose so many
problems practically that finally black
will crack under the pressure right okay
so the construction that we want to set
up
of course is our bishop on e5 our king
on h2
so that uh the bishop not only is
eyeballing g7 and tying black
up to the defense of the pawn on g7 but
with the king on h2 no there's just no
checks never mind a perpetual check but
no check at all
i
would think that it would be who white
to also put the pawn on c5 just to make
sure that there's no queen takes a3
tricks either now having said that you
put your pawn on c5 you put your bishop
on e5 you put your king on
on h2 you got everything that was the
problem that you started to mention
peter at some point you've got to put
your majority to use as well and whether
you play g4 or h4 and h5
once you
lift your kimono
uh you you do
offer perpetual check opportunities
maybe for your opponent
yeah i mean okay but magnus has to go g4
because he wants very much to put his
king on gc this is a perfectly
harmonious setup okay big question what
will happen next
and it was so nice to to see anatoly
carp of the legendary world champion in
the broadcast during the legends
tournament and i had a chance to listen
to the broadcast and when they were
discussing with judith pogba and with
sasha grishchuk some possession then
anatoly was saying and then
and then and exactly that's the way of
thinking of a super gm
that what will happen next it's all nice
that we got here it was clear that we
get here but how do we proceed from
there it was just i felt like it was
such a very nice moment i was so happy
to
to to have the chance of witnessing this
analysis online absolutely and it's
alikar about something very very special
indeed our 12th world champion
um uh peter while you were talking
the uh green bar just immediately below
your picture and now immediately below
my picture
just
jumped i mean it went
as we had an anonymous
three thousand dollar donation so we
don't know who to thank others to say
thank you very much
as the green bar in our donation
kiva uh who
what who's benefiting from the
tournament not just the name recognition
but also in the
i
that we're trying to raise 50 000
to assist them
in their uh drive
uh we just had a nice 3 000 donation so
a shout out to whoever did that thank
you so very very much indeed uh we did
see g4 we did see bishop d5 bishop d5
we've seen king g3
uh
well as you say i i don't know what's
going to happen next but i can imagine
h4h5 and then
exactly
we had a wonderful player from the
pacific northwest when i started playing
chess in 1972 i got caught up in the
bobby fischer boom and i think a lot of
players of my age
also got caught up in the same bobby
fischer boom we had a player from
british columbia his name was robert
zuke
and bob zuke was a very strong chess
master i think we would call him
international master player strength
today in those days
you know it was very very hard to get
neurons of any kind in any case bob zoo
was really really good at putting his
position his pieces on their ideal
position like if you look at
the the bishop and queen of black of
white for a moment and his king that
they're more or less on their ideal
squares right
and we would say that we reached the
zook point
and the zoo point was that you put all
your pieces on their maximum squares and
then you didn't have a plan
you had reached the apex
of everything that was possible you
didn't know how to go further so in a
certain way uh white has not quite
reached the zoo point he might put the
pawn on c5 the c3 punk could easily go
to c5 and the f4 punk could go to f5
hold on
timeout everything i was about to say
has changed
hikaru
made a huge decision peter he decided to
capture the pawn on a3
for the pawn on g7
yes i mean he took
okay for the reason why i'm not yet that
excited because i also see that white
has the very safe move queen a7 hitting
the f hitting the g7 pawn and you cannot
really play bishop f7 because then
i know you can but okay it doesn't
matter because i play queen a check and
you anyway have to go back and then i
can take capture the a for pawn i know
you can go king h7 because you're queen
okay this is the blindness we are also
getting tired okay but of course magnus
after queen takes ac captured on g7 but
this allowed black to play the move
queen c1
with [ __ ] the chances
bishop
as well magnus down to 29 seconds so he
doesn't have the time to
does this mean that after queenie one he
wants to go queen f2
uh
it has to mean that
there's just no other uh
there's no other choice otherwise it's
immediate draw but
that is a a remarkable reaction because
i'm thinking
are you thinking what i think i'm
thinking to trade queens and play h5 and
or first of all maybe just play a3
and
i
feel i'm
really close to a draw now
yeah it feels very large but that was
the problem that it got very much better
movies that after g4 that was the
problem that when you move when you
advance your pawn then immediately
suddenly you have a you have a target
from from black perspective and hikaru
immediately jumped on this target before
white confidently comfortably
would have increased the pressure and
queen f8 hit the pawn so f4 was kind of
obligatory hikaru immediately took on a3
yeah i don't mean to say that i mean
magnus has some unbelievable end game
specialty
and i just kind of felt that maybe c4 c5
just to restrict or prevent this ever
this possibility of queen a3 uh
oftentimes you know you're told i think
we have a rule in chess
if you have an advantage in the end game
don't rush
right just just keep nursing it and the
players
are moving right to that position and
well i yeah video little twist there was
a little twist just after bishop e5
hikaru did not give the check but he
first started with a3 okay
white played c4 queenie one check and
yeah not much drama has happened it's
the same position
usually this should be a draw but i mean
if white gets the pawn to g6 and his
king
then then it's a whole different story
so black has to make sure that he
he stops these pawns before they get too
far
right
and
well
gee uh
okay now i've got to think of what is
the correct setup that i want to make if
i'm black
should i be putting my bishop on e8
peter and my king on h7 and just
waiting for you to play
well no i don't
think i want to do that because you
could get so white wants to put his king
on f6 obviously and then he wants to go
h4 and g5 and g6 right
yeah exactly something like this because
if the pawn gets to g6 then it should be
winning right but but of course i mean
black has all kinds of whenever you
activate your king too fast then he will
start attacking the i mean put some yeah
but it's it's it's a tricky position
yeah because with the king on h7 if
white king gets towards e7 then even he
might be able to
to to sacrifice one of these pawns
so there is still i mean it's not an
elemental draw yet
not elementary by any means that is for
sure and we have seen the bishop coming
to c2
um
and i'm thinking that somehow my king
feels uh rather restricted on h7 maybe
well
is f7 the right square i'm having a
little
uh
somehow i'm getting myself into trouble
here
look at the clock i mean the clock
situation changed dramatically i mean
magnus is not the one with a comfortable
one and a half minute compared to
hikaru's 39 seconds okay
so bishop this he played king e5
everything according the plan but if
this king gets to f6 it gets really
really scary
okay so take us there uh peter imagine
the king gets to f6 the pawn gets to g6
and i'm just waiting oh so i'll start
with the move c5 just to give you
everything you want
uh exactly
because then you're yes so it goes okay
he got to move back the king to g8 okay
i mean okay the king on h7 was not
feeling happy at all no it was not uh
king f6 so c5 g5 trade trade trade
um
now exactly how do the pawns get
further
in other words
yeah i understand but i mean you really
need i mean thanks to this poem but is
this pawn saving you i mean if i go g6 i
go king g5 i'm gonna go f6
then you're gonna play somehow with c5
right i don't know how i wanted my pawn
on c5
so that there's not a bishop b4
situation right yeah but i mean i always
have bishop e5 so i have bishop e5
bishop d6 thank you
that
that's clearing some cobwebs okay so
hikaru is putting his bishop so it makes
it difficult to go
f7 check bishop takes f7 instantly so
white now needs to put his king on the
e7 square
yeah but i i do have this feeling that
thanks to this extra c pawn you're gonna
save this game
i mean that's that's my feeling somehow
but yeah c5 played because when i play
king e5 you might have
bishop to d3 right okay then i have f7
check
okay and that was why i wanted the pawn
on c5 yeah c5 played now
yeah so what it means is that after king
e5 everybody go ahead and play this move
bishop d3
so what
peter said f7 check if i go king
f8 you don't have bishop b4 but in this
case you have king f6 peter
yeah i have king f6
by the way we see it saw c5
and bishop e5
[Music]
on the live position peter
yeah this is the current position
yeah somehow this is exactly the problem
that white needs the e5 square for his
bishop and for his king and now magnus
start marching where does he he wanna
try to
go around
now this is the this is the weird thing
if you see the bar
uh on the light board the bar hasn't
moved the bar says draw draw draw
because you have a kind of a horizon
effect what peter was about to say is
the human player thinks
i can win this game with white i'm going
to go king b2 king c1 king
b2 king a3 and it may take me 15 20
moves but if i could ever bring my king
to the e7 square
that means i can support the move f7
f6 f7 and win the game now it might be
that this is beyond the computer's
horizon but peter you you would know it
far better than i
uh
i would think that the computer would
have this in some kind of end game
database
and it would just yeah but not this one
i mean this one definitely not this one
because this is not not a powerful
engine that's also not a purpose that
now suddenly the engine will tell
everything i mean let's enjoy the battle
and uh
yeah it's
it's it's very interesting but
it does feel that it should be i mean
this extra two pawns are always
disturbing
okay
right moment you can play a one queen
that will be the problem yeah and
whenever i take with the bishop you're
gonna go bishop e4 and in this sense it
was very important to sidestep with king
on f8 because there will never be f7
check and activating the bishop together
brilliant so put that together in
practical terms peter after the move
king b2 king g8 you were gonna wait for
white's king to get all the way up to
say b5 right
okay
yeah actually you know hikaru just the
way the game continues
wants to show that in fact the c pawn
had no impact whatsoever the point is
that
yeah you have to keep your bishop on the
long diagonal in order to keep this a1
check right thanks to a1 check and then
bishop e4 this is the way how i can
always escape
okay show us by example uh peter yeah i
mean try the envy i mean how are you
gonna
put put the bishop on d4 or put the
bishop on the long diagonal to release
my king
and i'll go king
yeah
yeah so okay let's just imagine i play
king f8 you go king b4 and now i'm gonna
push
a one queen you take and i hit your pawn
and thanks to the fact that the bishop
is on a1
it cannot go bishop to d6 check and then
push f7 check as well and win the game
because the bishop is on this terrible
uh
now a move like g7 check
you white has the extra two pawns but
now the blockade is forever there's no
uh breakthrough it's an easy easy draw
yeah so in fact yeah this is the key
that always
black will have the chance of playing a1
queen when he feels necessary yeah this
is probably the right moment and i saw
that
uh
i saw
the camera of
hikaru and hikaru was very much bobbing
his head like i got this i i know
i know i've got the draw
safely in the pocket and
uh
she's andrew agreed
and the draw is
wow
so hikaru nakamura wins the first set
yeah congratulations to hikaru of course
it's it's a great start for the match
but it's just the first very first step
of a very very long marches marathon
absolutely but hey uh
a long journey starts with the first
step and we did see in day one it's the
best of seven
and tanya a dramatic start to a finals
that we knew
was simply going to be a great
matchup
what a start we've had yes
nakamura takes the first set
in his matchup against the world
champion magnus carlson in this final
it could not have gone better for him
because it wasn't just about the
scoreline but if you saw that play that
he came with everything was on point and
i think we are
being joined by hikaru
hikaru are you can you hear us
i think you just take another second or
two to get set up but definitely tanya
uh you were just about to say it was a a
dream set
of games for hikaru
and he is here with us
congratulations hikaru on that uh
set one win
hikari can you hear us now
i think it just has some mute yeah
problems audio problems
we will
have him with us shortly
and there you have it second game win
winning the match
um
that fourth game it looked like perhaps
magnus has created something but hikaru
kept it under control i think it should
we should be good now hikaru can you are
you with us
we can't hear you i think it's perhaps
muted somewhere
well it's uh uh strange tanya that on
the very day
that uh
chesable had released the endgame course
of magnus it was actually the endgame
play of hikaru that carried the day as
he needed to draw this game four and he
did it two pawns down
yeah i mean to be honest it's also nice
to see hikaru suffer a little bit with
the technology because i know from
myself that you know i always had this
shock and i didn't know i mean if the
system is not working i'm done
but of course he could with all his
experience and even he gets fooled by
the technology this is this is even more
dramatic
exactly i come i completely concur uh
with you there peter i mean i have i am
the most the least
techn uh it's where technology is
concerned i'm the least gifted and it's
nice to see somebody er like hikaru who
as you say is you know like this
world-class streamer
uh and he knows the technology inside
and out having trouble uh
makes it bearable for somebody like me
yeah because it's all very tricky with
this microphone yeah because you you
plug in too many things and then the
zoom system and whatever takes over and
yeah it's
sometimes it can happen but i'm pretty
sure that in a
very short time we will sort this out
yeah absolutely peter hikaru will be
joining us shortly
but
what a what an insane start i mean i
have to say that for me the most
amazing thing to see was just simply it
felt like magnus never got going in any
of the games you could not point out
where he actually got a you know a good
position or got got his got his game on
it looked like hikaru came in with
extremely strong prep
had the clock situation
uh in control
and with that in the best of seven we
see hikaru nakamura taking his first set
yes you know i was watching the watching
both these players on camera
and i really got the feeling that
all right we're going to talk more about
that because i think hikaru is with us
now let's hope that he can hear us
hello
congratulations hikaru kin
hikaru can you
hear us right now we can hear you
no all right still facing that technical
situation we should have him with us uh
very soon yeah so i was saying yes did
you feel that magnus looked extremely
exhausted coming into today's game
it
tanya it's terrible i just can't read
magnus at all to me whenever i see
magnus he has got the california cool
i think we have ikaro i just
briefly i heard a mumble
i'll go back to you tanya yeah i think
he can uh
he's not able to hear us at the moment
uh we'll know shortly when we fix that
okay um
yes talking about body language yes i
think there are some players who make it
very clear and you know it's a joy to
watch them because every emotion that
they're going through while playing is
very apparent hikaru is one of them and
i think we saw that even in the last
game in the very last moments you could
literally see his mind racing with
trying to remember the setups on how
black holes this ending and where it is
and then when he figured it out he was
bobbing his head just
knowing that he had it and
magnus definitely more of a poker face
but again i think i think in today's
game it it kind of felt like the mental
fatigue is taking its toll and let me
just check if we've got hikaru with us
hello hey karo are you
able to hear our voice
while he while we fix this let's also
quickly take a look at the third game
that we had because i think that was
very fascinating uh peter and i'm sure
we're gonna have hikaru's thoughts on
this on this game release really soon
let's have that up on the board
[Music]
and this is where the g4 g with the move
a5 peter he was going for the full
clamp i felt and maybe this was an
overreach of sort but he came really
close
peter
yeah at this moment it looked like uh
hikaru is in total charge
and to be honest until this bishop b6 i
feel like this bishop b6 was based on
the oversight but we will definitely be
hearing hikaru's opinion about this
exactly uh because if you go forwards
for a few months tanya i think you were
about to say
that uh
it it kind of felt a little bit
desperate
for magnus at a certain moment and then
he karu
played this huge move bishop b6 he
didn't have to do that
yeah not at all i mean
somehow if you remember correctly magnus
had just like one and a half minute here
so he was desperately looking for some
contra chance to change the character of
the course of this game
and bishop b6 was exactly the move he
needed it and also we should not forget
that magnus had something like four
minutes when he spent almost three
minutes and he went for bishop h5 so
probably he has set this trap because
after bishop h5 it looks like aha you
cannot go bishop f5 because of bishop
takes f3 but there is this lovely
intermediate with bishop b6 because now
i remove my bishop i hit your bishop and
i'm starting bishop f5 but all of a
sudden
it turns out that black can capture this
very important pawn on g5 bishop f5
bishop g6 and things got out of control
exactly after the tree bishop takes
bishop takes d3 white wasn't winning an
exchange because we were on uh with john
urschel and these rooks on f1 and b1
means that uh
magnus was able to win his exchange back
eventually a very very scrappy affair
but a draw nonetheless i i felt that
that was a a huge save by magnus
yeah absolutely but at some point we
even got a little bit scared for for
hikaru but right
probably hikaru as being
extremely creative he had foreseen that
he is not this king
but to our eyes
it was it was kind of scary and all
these segments after knight f7 but
everything seemed to have worked out
almost by force and probably
uh hikaru had foreseen this and had
everything under control so there was a
natural result here
wow yeah and i think throughout the
match it was just amazing to see how
i can hear him
we can hear him but i'm not sure he
asked if he can hear us that's the
problem
i can hear him but he can't hear
we are trying us
fix that um but yes peter what you were
saying about just the end game play it
was absolutely fabulous i think
throughout the games and i think
especially in the last game in in game
four when magnus had to win
on demand
you know it was a slow opening a slow
start but just managing to create some
chances in this opposite color bishop
situation and going into this ending
where you've got this race with the fg
pawn i think kudos to the world champion
to really trying it out and hikaru
nakamura really knowing
how endings are played and how to defend
these positions because playing this in
30 seconds on the clock is really scary
and a really nice idea pointed out by
you peter this a2 pawn being extremely
important in defense it's been very
instructive for all of us but if we
really want to
learn how it's done and how to play
these endings another big reminder to
our to all our audience that
the magnus touch his course on ending
the world champion discusses and speaks
about and teaches us how to play end
games what are the important concepts
how to get those crucial points at that
critical stage and the courses are at a
40 percent inaugural off you can also
check out the free lesson by magnus
which is a 20 minute lesson
and um
uh
in which he discusses a game with
vishyana and so definitely have a look
and the big magnus touch
end game course is out now you don't
want to miss this one and i think
today's match has just has just clearly
shown us how important it is to know
your endings because these guys at the
very top i mean imagine this last game
of hikaru and magnus playing on seconds
if you don't know how it's done it's so
easy to mess this up
absolutely and tanya i just add uh i had
a friend michael j for net michael
fernett was the champion of washington
state uh several times and he said to me
very early in my career he said yes sir
uh studying endgames is like cheating on
an exam
because you know
you're going to play end games so you
might as well study them in advance and
it really it really hit me and i began
studying endgames and i really felt very
strongly
that because of my endgame study i
actually became a very strong player by
studying the end game so it's very
precipitous that
magnus releases his in-game course
exactly at this time
absolutely yes and while we are trying
to get hikaru to come and join us for
the interview he will be with us shortly
we are fixing that take a look at why
endings are so important and what is it
that magnus carlsen will be teaching us
in his course
ladies and gentlemen please take your
seats
the show is about to begin
[Music]
and you still seem kind of upset about
that inaccuracy yeah nine years later
yeah
which is why
whenever this game is brought up online
[Music]
our partner for the tour final is kiva
the non-profit with a mission to expand
financial access to help under-served
communities kiva does incredible work
providing micro loans to help people
around the world create opportunity for
themselves and their communities when
the pandemic started kiva set up a
global covid 19 response fund to help
small businesses get back on their feet
their target to raise 50 million dollars
to support thousands of people around
the world chess24 wants to help make
that happen during the tours final we
will be donating 50 of all proceeds from
new premium memberships to kiva go
premium and you will not just be
supporting us and getting the best chess
entertainment out there you will be
supporting people in times of need
through kiva and if you are premium
already you can buy sponsored premium
memberships for schools in cities and
countries of your choice in our shop
let's show how chess can play its part
together
[Music]
welcome back and we do have our winner
of set one with us today finally hikaru
congratulations
uh thanks yeah it was a tough match
[Music]
you say it was a tough match but i have
to say from our perspective it looked
like you were on your a game from the
start you had
it felt like you were dominating the
match and with the one in rhythm
throughout
as the match progressed did you feel
that it was going to be a good day in
office
well i mean i think when i won the
second game i figured at the very least
i'd probably get to tie breaks um
but yeah i think really it the result
seemed smooth but the way the third game
went kind of messed up the whole rhythm
because i think i was probably close to
winning at a couple points in that game
um and when i didn't win that game that
was sort of a big swing of the emotions
because i went from i think clearly
winning to maybe
just a little bit better and then me
possibly even losing for a move or two
and then back to a draw so i think the
swings were pretty big in that third
game um but for the most part i thought
i played well and even in the fourth
game when it was pretty bad i always
knew there would be chances to draw just
because of the opposite color bishops
hikaru what would you say was the
turning point in today's set would it be
winning game two or surviving game three
feeling it shaky
i mean it was winning game two obviously
because that gave me it gave me the
advantage um
i mean game three saving was important
but getting getting on the scoreboard
and getting the lead certainly was the
most important thing so so winning that
winning that second game the way that i
did i was very very happy with it and um
and that that was the most important one
uh for sure
all right and the one thing that really
stood out for us was just simply the
positions that you were getting out of
the opening it felt like you were you
were doing well on the clock uh your
openings were working out it looked like
solid prep coming into today's uh
game
yeah i mean i think the second game was
very messy of course but i was quite
pleased that i got to play this
variation against magnus because
i wanted something very sharp and very
very messy and when i got that in the
second game specifically
and then i was able to just keep finding
reasonable moves
that really gave me a lot of confidence
and somewhere yeah around this point
that i got this uh rookie hd like before
i got rook h8 i i thought maybe it was
just equal and then as soon as i saw
that magnus played g5 it's like oh i can
trade go rook h8 and then then um and
then everything i think falls apart for
white
and uh
what do you think hikaru was the one
thing that magnus troubled most with
today because what stood out to us was
that it just
it just felt that he never really got
going in today's uh today's match what
do you think he struggled most with
today
i mean i think magnus was trying to play
the way he's played throughout the last
two events which is he's tried to play
very sharp and aggressive with both
colors and um and i think the positions
are are slightly more suited to me is is
what i would say um in terms of the in
terms of the troubles he had especially
with black because in both the night or
games um well i think the position was
fine for black it was the moves weren't
simple it wasn't intuitive and it wasn't
natural i think that showed um based on
magnus's time usage so so probably i
would say the openings were the the
biggest issue for magnus today
right and now in game four it looked
like magnus had created something
seemingly out of nothing and were you
ever actually worried during this game
at any point or were you confident about
holding this i mean i was pretty upset
because i i missed queen b3 and then as
soon as he played e4 i saw it um and i i
spent like two minutes before going
queen d5
uh i i just didn't see it when i played
um when i played bishop to e6 i was
pretty unhappy but then i figured i
should go for it anyway and um
and yeah i think it was worse but
probably if there was some way magnus
could have um kept the kept the rooks on
the board i thought rookie one here was
probably the big mistake because
objectively after rookie won bishop f7 i
think all the queen end games are pretty
easy to hold whereas i think the rook
end games are probably a lot harder if
not losing um like if we get a five
versus four or four versus three with
rooks and bishops i think they're very
good winning chances we're in the queen
end game i think it's always uh it
always should be a draw so i was very
happy when i traded the rooks and he
wasn't able to take the a pawn um and
then then yeah i think from there it was
pretty pretty smooth sailing even though
there even though the end game gets a
little bit iffy um i i always had a
feeling it has to be a draw with the
opposite color bishops
and at the very end we saw you sort of
analyzing with your own self and uh
trying to remember you know the
positions that uh this holds on to what
was going on in your mind at that moment
it was very cool
no go ahead
no that's it's gone
i mean the problem is originally i
thought i could go king h6 i thought i
could leave the king on h7 and go king
h6 but that that loses um
that was the original thought i think it
loses at least i'm not 100 sure but i
thought that i could just sort of wait
here like bishop c2 king f6 bishop d3
um and then g5 takes takes bishop c2
and i thought this was a draw but
i mean actually the more i looked at it
now it might just be a draw but i was
very worried after like g6 king h6 that
there's some some trick with um i don't
know like bishop d2 i guess no this is a
draw because you can't go bishop d2
because i come up and you don't have
time to get king e7
um so actually this would have drawn two
so i guess my original idea does work
but i can still play passive with the
king on g8 as well and um and i wasn't
100 sure this was a draw but i figured
with the with the a2 pawn it should
always be it should always be a draw
does a21 is super critical in in
defending this position because the
bishop can just never lead the diagonal
right yeah and i mean basically it's
just a theoretical draw so i kind of i i
saw it coming
um when he started moving the king over
and i i knew it had to be a draw it was
just a matter of of making making the
right moves and putting the king like on
the right square specifically
he got in the interview after you beat
daniel you know you said that a magnus
has this thing where he just does these
little things just slightly better than
everybody else but today yes mentioned
that it looked like you were the one
doing all these little things uh
slightly better uh did you feel that
while playing today
yeah i mean i felt that i was really
putting the pressure on magnus i i could
tell expressing the third game he was
very unhappy with this position um
so so once again i i'm not going to
change my opinion and act like somehow
i'm i'm better or anything but what i
would say is that the small advantage is
that doesn't like in a game to game or a
match situation that necessarily that
won't necessarily be reflective but when
you look at hundreds and hundreds of
games um there is a difference so uh
today i felt that in this match i really
took advantage of the opportunities that
i had and um i i really felt i played
played pretty well throughout i mean
maybe maybe the third game allowing this
uh this this pawn to hang on g5 is
really really stupid but for the most
part um i thought i thought i played
well and i i
i got exactly what i wanted so i'm very
happy i think the result was was was of
course the best one that i could have
hoped for
uh absolutely i think a
dream start to the final and very very
impressive quality of play as well uh
it's a very long
match it's the best of seven how
important is it to take this early lead
uh going into the finals i mean i i
don't think it really matters you know i
think i think it was like a best of
three or best of five it would be a lot
different but i think in a best of seven
um with so many more matches ahead it
really doesn't doesn't make a big
difference other than the fact you need
to win one last match out of the seven
um but i would say in investor seven
especially i don't think it plays a huge
role other than other than the fact that
i mean magnus has to win one more match
than i do at this point
and i have to ask you one more question
uh hikaru uh before we get into some
critical details of the game uh that
you know you have this great opening
prep that you came with and uh you have
this final going on you you're streaming
you're traveling how are you finding the
time to do all this how
how are you how are you managing
it looks like you never sleep
yeah i mean well actually i mean i i'm
probably not gonna have time to go over
the games in in detail because i
actually have to run out and go go to go
do a television appearance on on them on
a show very soon um so so what i would
say is that uh you know you just do your
preparation i think more more so than
that it's just you know the fans kind of
are giving me a lot of the the
inspiration the drive and um and i'm
just doing what i can and it seems to be
working out
all right well congratulations i don't
know do you have do you have just a
couple more minutes but you need to rush
right now i mean i'm gonna have to go in
like 10 minutes so i i really do have to
get going i'm gonna hand it over to yas
and to peter just for one or two
critical moments that they want to take
you through to the game is that fine
sure
all right thanks uh yes peter thank you
tanya congratulations hikaru everything
you said uh yeah you just you were just
the better player today
i think it was all about the pivotal
game too that you won with the black
pieces
and that was an opening that you
well i don't know how much experience
you've had in it just uh
tell us a little bit more about your
opening choice and how you came to make
that because that was the that was the
game that won you the today set i guess
first thing i would say is that i saw um
the game between uh in the last match
between magnus and dean loren that was
sort of the first inspiration for it and
then secondly um you know when in doubt
play like fabiano plain and simple i
mean fabian is the one who came up with
this i believe this whole b5 idea um
when he played in st louis a couple
years back so really you know just play
like fabiano play good openings
wonderful thank you i'll turn it over to
peter peter
yeah congratulations hikaru it was a
great start i mean already seeing the
first game it was such a high quality
game we felt like this day will be
special uh one one question right at the
beginning because during the broadcast i
was telling you yasser was completely
shocked what is this bishop h4 and i
told him if i'm not mistaken then you
yourself had played this bishop h4 like
in 2013 in one of these video grand prix
am i'm right uh i played against fabiano
in the top and the town memorial i don't
know if it was this exact line with
bishop h4 but i did play this 95 bish 5
against him um
and uh it was in the town memorial 2000
i think it was even earlier i think it
was like 2012. i think it was 2012 um at
the tomorrow fabiano the white piece i
had the black piece when we played this
so i was trying to remember it um and i
just i knew that there were a couple set
up for white should be better that
that's what i remember vaguely from when
i from when i did the preparation all
those years ago and um i just tried to
play something natural
yeah i mean certainly it looked very
very nice and just one question in this
third game i mean bishop b6 was it and
simply oversight that you blundered that
magnus can take on g5 or yeah yeah i
just blundered it i just wondered that
takes bishop five bishop g6 um it's
oddly enough it's still probably winning
for white but i think psychologically
when you think you're about to win the
game and you blunder like this i mean
not just win the game but win the match
if you win the game um it's very hard to
recover but fortunately i was able to uh
play some play some okay moves after
that i would say and um i was able to
make the draw
yeah
yeah i mean it was a fascinating fight i
mean i also don't want to torture you
because it was a very intense match and
the marathon has just started
so thank you very much and i hand it
back to tanya congratulations hikari
thank you so much and we'll see you
tomorrow all right thank you bye
bye
nakamura taking the lead in the match
with the first set victory beating world
champion magnus carlsen two and a half
one and a half what quality play from
hikaru absolutely impressive in the
opening taking the chances in the middle
game keeping things in control and when
things started looking a little messy in
the endgame just knowing what to do and
keeping it all together
yeah so your thoughts on how today went
absolutely first of all
uh boldly stating the obvious it's a
dream
start indeed for hikaru and if he's
going to win the match this is how he is
going to win the match he's going to do
it through superior opening preparation
a preparation that gets him ahead of on
the clock keeps an end on the clock and
keeps the world champion on the back
foot and today is uh
just it's just perfect i mean you know
sometimes you go into a game or a match
and you have your preparation and you
pinch yourself because you said wow
uh it all goes so well
it's not going to go as perfectly as it
did today every day but
this is a dream start for hikaru peter
your thoughts
yeah absolutely i mean we had been
expecting a thrilling final between
these two extraordinary players but i
think we couldn't have expected this
first day because this was very very
intense i also love that we have this
format because now
i think every professional every chess
player is looking forward to what will
magnus carson change in order to
to get the initiative back in this match
i believe if we would ask magnus about
today's match he might point out that
you know guys everything was under
control yes we had very tough battles
but the game two that i lost i actually
had all the chances of winning them and
by losing that game that was the only
only problem uh but i do believe that
magnus and his team will feel like that
yeah maybe these openings that
they were absolutely fine however
as he could also pointed out and we are
during the broadcast witness that magnus
was burning way too much time and it's
not the usual magnus we have been seeing
before usually he likes to control the
happenings and i think this gave the
psychological advantage to hikaru which
he made very good use of at the end
peter i completely agree with you and i
think uh kudos to team hikaru for
putting up these brilliant openings and
having the clock situation in hand
definitely team magnus will have to make
some changes going into day two we're
all very excited about that but the one
team yes and peter that i am really
proud of is team chess community because
as you guys have seen on the kiva bar
that was on the screen before i just
popped up we have made
such a big jump into our contribution we
are over 20k and we've had some amazing
donations we've had in a non a big
anonymous donation to this cause he we
had we had vp of growth of
growth kiva come on to the show who told
us
just how it works and how
everything that we are doing by
going premium investing in our own chess
education improving our own chest is
what a brilliant opportunity this is for
all of us to also leave a big impact on
the society on the individuals and a big
thank you and a shout out to yan
christoph duda who's contributed
1299 euros almost 1300 euros in premium
membership towards kiva's cause of
raising funds to support individuals
entrepreneurs businesses startups in
underserved isolated communities and the
best part is that the contribution can
be followed up we can actually see the
journey of the money that we give out to
the community to the society to help
them come out of this pandemic stronger
and now more than ever as uh as enrique
put it is the time to help and to do the
most that we can to support to support
the community around us and when we have
people like tani come on this show and
we have jon urschel come in the show
these are the stories that shine and
that tell us just what an impactful game
chess is just just the big impact that
it leads on us and how it's this tool
that we can use to give out to the world
and also i'm very sure that when things
normalize and we're actually able to get
out i think chess is going to play a
huge role in rebuilding the community
and coming out of this extremely
challenging time even stronger
so definitely consider going premiums
supporting what chess 24 does supporting
the magnus carlsen chest or
having making sure that we're able to
put out these events and do all these
innovative activities around chess
whether it's the banter blitz whether we
bring you q a's whether it's the video
resources and video series by world
champion and by by different world
champions to all of you if you can
support that consider going premium and
no better time than now to do it because
50
of all premium memberships are going to
go into kiwa's cause of raising money
for the community
yes peter we've also had an incredible
incredible audience with us all
throughout who have been a part of this
show from from the very start from game
one and so much coming in so much
support coming in for hikaru so many
come back madness messages coming in
let's take a look at some of the
conversations that we've been having
[Music]
and take a look at this thank you should
be writing in with the classic concept
of chess store i mean honestly guys what
a tour it's been it's just been
absolutely fabulous from the word go we
had
mc invitational that's where it all
started within two weeks of all sports
being stopped the candidates being
stopped chess 24 put the entire magnus
carlson chess door
together set the whole thing up with the
best in the world
so much prize fun to fight for the
absolute
the absolute elite of the chess well the
best of the best coming and and
showcasing world-class chess for us to
enjoy with with gold standards of
broadcast with commentators we've had
world champions come on it's just been
absolutely fabulous and then we had
heritage chess the linderis abbey
tournament which was
which was
just incredible who can forget hikaru
nakamura knocking out magnus carlson in
that semi-final and then we have the
chessable masters with the hashtag
bloody chess and yes of course the study
of chess never stops because let's not
forget that today is the day the big
cost the magnus touch on end games
releases with a 40 off on the inaugural
price you can also check out the free
lesson on endgame that magnus has done
which is a teaser of what the course is
all about it's a 20 minute free lesson
and you will know why you need to get
your hands on this course by the world
champion the endings and we've seen it
throughout the tour we've seen it in our
own careers we've seen it in our own
games just how important and how complex
these so-called
simple looking with fewer pieces in the
board position are but just the kind of
skills that they require let's have that
let's have our next tweet up
we have grand master dennis riding in
with a big second round win for nakamura
nakamura seems to be dictating the
rhythm so far but the question remains
can carlsen bounce back yes peter
is carlson bouncing back as soon as
tomorrow
well
uh as they say you're gonna have to tune
in uh to find the out the answers of
that question i would say yes that uh
magnus is going to bounce back and we
can have a very very competitive match
from my perspective i thought that this
was a dream start for hikaru he's going
to try to do the same thing that brought
him success and as peter you just said i
mean this was all
you know all four games were
were pretty close neptune tuck and it
was only that game two which
maybe uh
was in the favor
of the world champion before he lost
control so
i mean it it's going to be a close match
we can't read too deeply into the result
of the first set uh peter
yeah i remember that
the magnus
fi i mean the skiva final in the magnus
tour started with england beating the
world champion in the first set in a
very impressive manner and you remember
really concerned for magnus how he will
deal with the situation coming right
after the legends and so on and we have
seen we got the answer from the world
champion how he deals with such
situations so will be very interesting
uh how magnus will turn the turn the
tables
uh of course he has all the chances but
i mean hikaru is in very very good shape
and
i think also by winning sets as hikaru
said it might not mean that much but
psychologically i think it gives you the
feeling that i'm able to beat the world
champion and if you are
able to build up your psychological
state and you just kind of take it like
automatic that things go your way it can
be of of a very very important asset
during the match so mangos has to make
sure to to turn the tides as quickly as
possible before his opponent gets
overconfident which would be even
more difficult for magnus to come back
later
exactly thank you peter uh by the way
tanya i just didn't want to get in the
comment regarding uh what the twitter i
i think first of all the magnus carlsen
tour has been terrific the competition
has been great the prize fund has been
fantastic the audience participation has
been great
but also there are a lot of people who
work behind the scenes to bring the
broadcast and we just got to give a
shout out to satirist and lewis in our
particular case for this broadcast i
mean there are a lot a lot of tech
technical challenges
and when the show goes beautifully you
know those are the people to thank so
big shout out to them and always and
always and always to our audience or
just participating and uh being well
pushing us urging us on thank you thank
you
everyone
bang on yes i think it's the audience
for which we do all of this and which
keep us going and i think peter that was
the key point what you made that
absolutely a huge confidence boost for
hikaru nakamura knowing
that
it wasn't about any luck here he to a
certain extent felt especially in some
games he outplayed the world champion
and what we are seeing is a very inform
in shape a well-rested hikaru nakamura
in a format that suits him incredibly
well but of course
there could be no tougher challenge to
win the finals than what hikaru has
which is facing the world's best player
magnus carlsen let's take a look at a
few more tweets that we had
let's bring those up we heard from hajj
are these seven days going to be super
thrilling with a lot of solid openings
awesome end game fireworks just the
first game was awesome was wow son that
white rook h1 move was an absolute time
saver
you are right harsh i mean i think that
was an incredible game one it ended in a
draw it was the result was even but the
game was absolutely insane such creative
ideas by magnus by hikaru right here on
rook h1 and then we saw this this i mean
you
you play rook g1 with a pawn on g3 i
think that was amazing with the thread
of g4 a couple of moves ago and then you
bring the rook back to h1 we don't see
that very often in chess and just
such creativity and taking his chances
playing confidently what a day it's been
for hikaru nakamura and this game even
though it ended in a draw i think was
was a very very exciting start to the
day let's move on to the next tweet
we had rick riding in with chess 24
watching two of my favorite players go
head to head and raising money for kiva
at the same time rick you are absolutely
right i think whether you're team magnus
or your team hikaru you have to agree
that this is a dream final this is truly
the final between the two of the best
players in the world in this format and
we could not have asked for more
and with all with this with this
incredible final setup to see who really
is the best player right now in this
format in the magnus carlson chess store
to be able to support the community
through kiva while going through this
it's really a special experience and
with that i am going to sign out for the
day with a quick reminder to you because
you know what a lot of us there's no
such thing as too much chess the magnus
carlsen chess
course the magnus touch on end games is
live now it is out on chesapeal you have
to check it out you can check out the
free lesson the teaser which is a free
lesson a 20 minute lesson on end games
by magnus carlsen and the full cost is
on a 40
off definitely give that
just just go and watch it and we'll be
back tomorrow with more action
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen please take your
seats the show is about to begin
[Music]
and you still seem kind of upset about
that
inaccuracy no years later yeah
which is why
whenever this game is brought up
[Music]
you